debatte vor ein paar momenten schon
begonnen wir haben jetzt gleich rein
momentan am podium ist die helge lind
der hier auch einen vorschlag
eingereicht hat unter anderem fordert
dort eine gruppe von abgeordneten ein
netz von staatlichen anerkannten
beratungsstellen alles weitere dann noch
gleich verlieren beim assistierten
suizid also eine unterstützung für
denjenigen der sterbens willig ist oder
noch ringt aber auch für diejenigen die
helfen wollen und denen das nicht
verunmöglicht werden darf ohne sie dazu
zu zwingen von dieser perspektive aus
wollen wir denken und nicht von der
perspektive
fragwürdiger sterbehilfe vereine aus und
nicht von der perspektive einer
sterbehilfe infrastruktur aus denn
machen wir uns klar wenn wir von der
perspektive ausdenken
vergessen wir dass diese vereine und
diese situation letztlich nur entstanden
sind weil es keine andere möglichkeit
gegenwärtig gibt
rechtssicher und tatsächlich zu helfen
und dieser richtige einzig richtige weg
ist derjenige über das
vertrauensverhältnis des betroffenen
sterbewilligen und des arztes und ärzten
kein anderer
dabei immer als möglichkeit als recht
als freiheit des arztes und der ärztin
zu helfen nicht als zwang
daher legen wir auch entschieden wert
darauf zu sehen das in form einer
umfassenden beratung auch der einzelnen
die einzelne entscheiden kann informiert
wird auch über die konsequenzen eines
möglichen
fehlschlagen nicht funktionieren suizids
über die auswirkung auf die angehörigen
wirklich voll umfänglich informiert
nicht in richtung suizid sondern
ergebnisoffen denn nur informierte gut
aufgeklärte beratende individuen und per
so können wirklich autonom und frei
entscheiden und das ist was wir wollen
und was wir unterstützen wollen ja mit
müssen und sogar ethisch geboten sind
dies zu tun in diesem sinne auch kann
eine solche form der assistenz sogar
suizid präventiv sein denn für viele ist
das wissen dass sie irgendwann die
möglichkeit haben unterstützt aus dem
leben zu scheiden wenn sie dieses leben
nicht mehr als erträglich achten befreit
sie
nimmt ihn manchmal auch ja nicht selten
die ärztin er zu berichten einen aktiven
sterbewunsch und entlastet sie ja bringt
sie dazu jetzt gegenwärtig noch aktive
um das leben zu kämpfen kämpfen zu
wollen
insofern ist auch diese möglichkeit
präventiv daher bitten wir sie
unterstützen sie unseren gesetzesentwurf
wir wollen anwälte sein cool der
betroffenen sterbewilligen wie auch der
helfenden und auch des lebens nicht des
abstrakten sondern ihres konkretes aber
wir wollen nicht richter seien über den
einzelnen und seiner autonomen
getroffene entscheidung
haye gelingt war das konnte der spd
diese orientierungs debatte findet jetzt
statt ohne fraktionszwang können sich
hier die abgeordneten äußern deswegen
gibt es hier auch schon er einige
vorschläge die
fraktionsübergreifend vorgeschlagen
wurden hier gelingt hat ja auch einen
vorgeschlagen der bundestag hat schon
vor gut einem jahr über die sterbehilfe
diskutiert damals hat man keine einigung
finden können und dann kam halt die
bundestagswahlen deswegen gibt es jetzt
sozusagen in dieser legislaturperiode
wieder eine erste orientierung debatte
denn das ist
notwendig weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht im februar 2020
das verbot geschäftsmäßiger sterbehilfe
so wie es bis dahin galt als
verfassungswidrig erklärt hat und
deswegen gibt es jetzt hier wieder diese
orientierung debatte
bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau
erläutert hier noch die regeln dafür
wenn ich jetzt die überzogene zeit des
kollegen sind die nächsten redner oder
der nächsten rednerinnen der spd
fraktion ab ziel die vielleicht eine
andere position vertritt dann wird es
nicht nur ungerecht sondern wurde es
auch schwierig diese debatte in der
entsprechenden auch verabredeten art und
weise und mit würde zu gestalten also
tun sie mir bitte den gefallen und
achten sie darauf dass sie die
vereinbarten redezeiten einhalten also
sie hat hier noch mal darauf hingewiesen
normalerweise wenn ein abgeordneter
einer fraktion überzieht dann wird
innerhalb dieser fraktion dann diese
redezeit einem anderen redner abgezogen
da aber eben wie ich gesagt habe hier
kein fraktionszwang
herrscht sondern die abgeordneten nach
ihrem gewissen hier sprechen ist das
schwierig das dann umzusetzen nächster
redner ist jetzt ansgar heveling cdu csu
kollegen vor etwas über siebeneinhalb
jahren im november 2014 haben wir hier
im plenum schon einmal über suizid
assistenz und sterbebegleitung
debattiert der seinerzeitige
bundestagspräsident norbert lammert
sprach von dem vermutlich
anspruchsvollsten gesetzgebungs projekt
der damaligen wahlperiode argumente und
emotionen breiten aufeinander die wie
nur wenige andere als existenziell
bezeichnet werden können die intensive
diskussion und der anschließend
gefundene kompromiss führten zu einer
der viel gerühmten sternstunden des
parlaments nun befinden wir uns nach
siebeneinhalb jahren wieder hier im
plenarsaal des bundestages und wieder
debattieren wir über suizid assistenz
aber wie heißt es bereits bei heraklit
man kann nicht zweimal in denselben
fluss steigen auch wenn wir heute wieder
über die suizid assistenz sprechen
führen wir nicht die diskussion des
jahres 2014 fort sondern sind mit der
entscheidung des zweiten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
aus 2020 in einer neuen situation dort
hat das gericht ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben als ausdruck
persönlicher autonomie anerkannt und
dieses recht so das
bundesverfassungsgericht umfasst auch
die freiheit hierfür bei dritten hilfe
zu suchen und hilfe soweit sie angeboten
wird in anspruch zu nehmen aber schon
dieser verfassungsrechtlich eindeutige
ausgangspunkt wirft in der praxis
komplexe fragen auf wann ist der wunsch
dem eigenen leben ein ende zu setzen
ausdruck persönlicher autonomie wie soll
man herausfinden ob die entscheidung
eines sterbewilligen vielleicht gar
nicht selbst gesetzten gründen
entspringt sondern er sich sozialen
druck ausgesetzt sieht oder an einer
krankheit leidet die es ihm unmöglich
macht seinen wunsch zu sterben und
selbstbestimmt zu reflektieren diese
situationen voneinander abzugrenzen ist
keineswegs trivial denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat auch
unmissverständlich zum ausdruck gebracht
dass der staat dafür sorge zu tragen hat
dass der entschluss begleiteten suizid
zu begehen
tatsächlich auf heim will gut angesichts
der unumkehrbarkeit des vollzugs einer
suizid entscheidung so das
bundesverfassungsgericht
gebiete die bedeutung des lebens als ein
höchstwert innerhalb der
grundgesetzlichen ordnung selbsttötungen
entgegenzuwirken die nicht von freier
selbstbestimmung und eigene
verantwortung getragen sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen hier
liegt die zentrale aufgabe jeder
zukünftigen regelung die den
verfassungsrecht gerichtlichen vorgaben
gerecht werden will die autonomie des
einzelnen
die autonomie des einzelnen und seine
daraus resultieren das recht auf
selbstbestimmte sterben müssen ebenso
geschützt werden wie das leben das ist
kein paradox sondern zeigt das leben und
sterben nicht losgelöst voneinander
betrachtet werden können über seinen tod
frei entscheiden kann nur wer liebt wer
einmal die grenze zum tod überschritten
hat kann seine entscheidung nicht
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass sich der
staat schützend vor das leben des
einzelnen stellt weil nur so auch die
autonomie des einzelnen geschützt werden
kann
ein
effektiver schutz der freie
verantwortlichkeit der entscheidung zur
selbsttötung verlangt die
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung grundsätzlich unter strafe
zu stellen dabei geht es nicht um die
suizid assistenz als solche sondern
gegen die förderung von
geschäftsmodellen die dazu führen dass
die selbsttötung als normalfall der
lebens beendigung gehandelt wird es ist
bekannt dass in ländern in denen die
geschäftsmäßige suizid assistenz
weitgehend schrankenlos angeboten wird
die selbsttötung daten ausgesprochen
hoch sind wichtig ist es vielmehr im
rahmen eines klaren schutz konzeptes
ausnahmen für menschen zu schaffen die
frei und ernsthaft den entschluss
gefasst haben aus dem leben scheiden zu
wollen dazu bedarf es erstens der
feststellung der frei verantwortlichkeit
der entscheidung zur selbsttötung durch
fachärzte für psychiatrie und eine
umfassende
ergebnisoffene beratung als zweites in
sondersituationen etwa bei einer
fortgeschrittenen unheilbaren erkrankung
bei einer zugleich begrenzten
lebenserwartung kann die feststellung
schneller getroffen werden nur so durch
eine strafrechtliche regelung und ein
schutzkonzept hat ausnahme schützen wir
wirksam die selbstbestimmung und das
wegen vielen dank
ansgar heveling war dass auch er hat
sich an einem vorschlagen beteiligt in
dem unter anderem gefordert wird dass
die geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung grundsätzlich strafbar
bleibt aber unter gewissen umständen
nicht strafrechtlich verfolgt wird und
kirsten kappert gonther hat sich auch
diesem vorschlag
angeschlossen
wenn wir über assistierten suizid reden
geht es im wahrsten sinne um leben und
tod und diese orientierungs debatte die
gibt uns die gelegenheit
argumente noch einmal abzuwägen und
eigene gewissheiten zu überprüfen
suizidalität ist häufig
in der regel haben menschen im laufe
ihres lebens auch mal suizidale gedanken
und darum ist es so wichtig dass wir das
tabu brechen und suizidalität
entstigmatisieren es fördert nämlich
nicht etwa suizidalität darüber zu reden
sondern es hilft dabei andere wege zu
finden
[Musik]
und die vorstellung
die häufig mal auch als argument
angeführt wird die vorstellung dass mit
der förderung des assistierten suizid
die sogenannten harten reduzierte also
die ziele reduziert würden die es leider
ein trugschluss
suizidalität entsteht immer im kontext
der lebenssituation suizid wünsche sind
in der regel nicht der wunsch nach dem
tod sondern der wunsch nach einer pause
von einer als unerträglich empfundenen
lebenssituation
über mehr als zwei jahrzehnte habe ich
als fachärztin für psychiatrie und
psychotherapie viele menschen in
suizidalen krisen begleitet und ich
finde es ist entscheidend dass wir hier
die prävention an erste stelle setzen
und dafür
hat eine gruppe der ich auch angehöre
bereits einen vorschlag gemacht einen
antrag zur stärkung der suizidprävention
und wir legen zudem mit dieser
interfraktionellen gruppe von
abgeordneten aller demokratischen
fraktionen ein gesetzentwurf zur
regulierung der suizidbeihilfe vor der
das angebot von assistierten suizid den
zugang unter klare regeln stellt eine
gesellschaft in der schwierig ist eine
gute pflege an krisenhilfe an eine
psychotherapie platz zu kommen aber es
womöglich an jeder ecke oder auch in
jedem pflegeheim eine umfasst
infrastruktur für den assistierten
suizid gebe dass wir für mich ein horror
szenario
wir dürfen doch mensch in not mit ihren
problemen nicht alleine lassen
stattdessen muss es buchstäblich an
jeder brücke hinweise für eine jederzeit
erreichbar suizid hotline geben
auch online auch anonym und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns nun
aufgetragen die suizid assistenz zu
regeln mein kollege heveling ist schon
darauf eingegangen und der
regelungsbedarf ist virulent denn
zurzeit findet suizid assistenz statt
aber ohne eine gesetzliche rahmen das
gericht auch klargestellt dass besonders
gefahr trächtige angebote der
suizidbeihilfe verboten werden können
und dass ein schutzkonzept sinnvoll ist
gerade um die autonomie abzusichern
meine gruppe setzt sich für eine
verankerung im strafrecht ein um eine
möglichst widerspruchsfreie gesetzgebung
umzusetzen der suizid assistenz anbietet
zum beispiel sterbehilfe vereine muss
sich an einen mehr augen prinzip und
wartefristen halten andernfalls macht er
sich strafbar und es wäre der tragweite
der entscheidung keinesfalls angemessen
wenn ein beamter am schreibtisch in der
arzneimittelbehörde mit einem stempel
ein suizid quasi staatlich absegnet im
gegenteil wer suizid assistenz anbietet
muss sicherstellen dass der suizid
wunsch freiverantwortlich entstanden ist
denn darum geht es liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen um selbstbestimmung und warum
nun setzt autonomie und selbstbestimmung
ein gutes schutzkonzept voraus das
klingt ja für einige vielleicht erst mal
kontra intuitiv eine selbstbestimmte
entscheidung setzt voraus dass diese
frei von inneren und äußeren
drucksituationen getroffen wurde
selbstbestimmung bedeutet eben die wahl
zu haben die selbstbestimmung aber ist
gefährdet wo der suizid wunsch durch
drucksituation wie seelische krisen
armut aber auch das gefühl anderen zur
last zu fallen oder sich überflüssig zu
fühlen geht es braucht also sinnvolle
prozedurale regelungen gerade um die
autonomie sicherzustellen und für kinder
davon bin ich fest überzeugt sollte der
suizid der assistierte suizid klipp und
klar ausgeschlossen deren den
sterbehilfe
denn sterbe wünsche sind eben volatil
und das gilt ganz besonders für kinder
und jugendliche wir in unserer gruppe
sagen regeln wer den assistierten suizid
aber fördern ihn nicht stellen wir
sicher dass die autonomie gewahrt wird
und flankieren wir eine gesetzliche
regelung zum assistierten suizid mit
einer guten suizidprävention danke sehr
kirsten kaputt konter war das mitglied
der grünen in einem vorschlag dem sich
die nächste rednerin angesprochen hat
katrin helling klar geht es im gegensatz
zu dem vorschlag von ihrer vorrednerin
datum das die regelung zum
suizidhilfe außerhalb des strafrechts
formuliert wird
jahren streite ich inzwischen gemeinsam
mit dr petra sitte mit helga lenz mit dr
till steffen mit otto fricke und vielen
anderen gemeinsam für eine liberale
sterbehilfe regelung für die menschen in
unserem land seit jahren erreichen mich
tagtäglich nachrichten von menschen die
mir uns ihre lebensumstände ihre
schicksale schildern die schmerzen haben
die angst haben ich kann es gut
verstehen wenn man selbst bestimmen
möchte wann und wie das eigene leben
endet und ich kann gut verstehen dass
man emotional die sicherheit haben
möchte gehen zu dürfen wenn es für ein
selbst so weit ist
den menschen in ihren bedürfnissen zur
seite zu stehen ist meine motivation
ich streite für eine liberale
sterbehilfe regelungen weil ich den
menschen die sicherheit geben möchte
dass sie ihr im grundgesetz verankertes
recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
ausüben können wenn sie es für geboten
halten deshalb ist es für mich
indiskutabel eine neue regelung der
sterbehilfe im strafrecht überhaupt nur
anzudenken ich finde wir sollten
denjenigen die bereit sind menschen auf
ihrem letzten weg zu begleiten ihnen zu
helfen mit respekt begegnen statinen mit
strafe bedrohten
schaffen wir für die menschen
stattdessen mit einem liberalen
sterbehilfe gesetz rechtsklarheit ohne
uns noch einmal moralisch über sie zu
erheben das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
ganz klar gesagt einen gegen die
autonomie gerichteten lebensschutz kann
und darf es nicht gibt stehen wir
menschen die über einen suizid
nachdenken zur seite indem wir
flächendeckend und bundesweit
niederschwellige beratungsmöglichkeiten
schaffen etablieren wie echte
anlaufstellen und bieten wir dort auf
konkrete hilfe zum beispiel auf dem weg
ins pflegeheim an
schließlich aber auch so ehrlich und
eröffnen denjenigen der sich entscheiden
gehen zu wollen die möglichkeit nach
beratung und ärztlicher verschreibung
ein medikament wie natrium pentobarbital
das ja auch in der schweiz anwendung
findet zu erhalten denn ich finde es
gebietet die menschlichkeit betroffene
mit ihrem recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben nicht mehr alleine zu lassen und
sie nicht weiter auf risikoreichere
methoden gar auf brutal suizide zu
verweisen aber lassen wir vertraute
ärzte über verschreibung entscheiden
nicht anonyme behörden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich war bei der
entscheidung zur § 2 17 strafgesetzbuch
in karlsruhe das urteil
das bundesverfassungsgericht vor
inzwischen gut zwei jahren gesprochen
hat war unmissverständlich und ist
wegweisend ich möchte uns alle aufrufen
das urteil und seine erwägungen zu
achten das recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben braucht ausreichend raum es darf
nicht noch einmal wegen zu hoher
gesetzlicher würden faktisch leer laufen
das sind wir den menschen in unserem
land schuldig vielen dank
das training klar hat hier auch nochmal
das urteil aus karlsruhe erwähnt in dem
die richter unter anderem gesagt haben
dass das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht
auch als ausdrucken persönlichkeit
persönliche autonomie ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben umfasst thomas
seitz spricht jetzt auf die fraktion
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die selbsttötung ist in
deutschland straflos bei kein fremdes
rechtsgut verletzt wird damit ist
grundsätzlich auch die förderung der
selbsttötung straflos im jahr 2015 wurde
deshalb mit dem verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der
selbsttötung eine beihilfe handlung zum
eigenständigen delikt erhoben seit 2020
das bundesverfassungsgericht diese
vorschrift für mit dem grundgesetz
unvereinbar erklärt hat fehlt es
jenseits des ärztlichen standesrecht es
wieder an einer regelung dies bedeutet
rechtsunsicherheit und die gefahr von
auswüchsen der gesetzgeber ist also
gefordert den assistierten suizid zu
regeln die vorgaben haben gesetzeskraft
und sind eindeutig zitat das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben erstreckt sich
auch auf die entscheidung des einzelnen
sein leben eigenhändig zu beenden und
weiter das recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben ist nicht auf fremd definierte
situationen wie schwere oder unheilbare
krankheitszustände beschränkt eine
einengung des schutzbereichs auf
bestimmte ursachen und motive liefe auf
eine bewertung der beweggründe zur
selbsttötung und auf eine inhaltliche
vorbestimmung hinaus die mit dem
freiheitsgedanken des grundgesetzes
fremd sind nach entscheidung auf der
einzelne selbst entscheiden was sein
verständnis für lebensqualität und
sinnhaftigkeit seiner existenz ausmacht
staat und gesellschaft haben diese
entscheidung als akt autonome
selbstbestimmung zu respektieren mit
diesen vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichts muss die zu
schaffende regelung einen zumutbaren weg
zu einem selbstbestimmten freitod
eröffnen was einen legalen zugang zum
betäubungsmittel natrium-pentobarbital
erfordert festzuhalten ist aber auch
dass kein arzt oder apotheker
verpflichtet ist an der selbsttötung
eines anderen mitzuwirken gleich seite
gebiete die schutzpflicht für das leben
ein tragfähiges schutzkonzept für einen
freien suizid bedarf es zunächst einer
fähigkeit der freien willensbildung und
der fähigkeit auch nach dieser einsicht
zu handeln
die willensbildung muss frei von
beeinträchtigungen durch krankheit seien
vor allem durch akute psychische
störungen ein problem gerade bei
betagten und schwerkranken menschen die
oft unter suizidgedanken infolge einer
depression leiden weiter muss der
betroffene gut informiert sein um auf
einer soliden beurteilungsgrundlage das
für und wider realistisch abzuwägen dazu
gehört insbesondere das verhandlungs
alternativen zum suizid erkennt ihre
jeweiligen folgen bewertet und sich in
kenntnis aller erheblichen umstände und
optionen entscheidet
ebenso muss gewährleistet sein dass sich
der betroffene frei von zwang drohung
täuschung oder sonstigen formen der
beeinflussung für den suizid entscheidet
die regelung muss auch sicherstellen
dass der entschluss aus dem leben zu
scheiden von einer gewissen
dauerhaftigkeit und inneren festigkeit
getragen ist dann nach den gerichtlichen
vorgaben je nach lebenssituation
unterschiedliche anforderungen an den
nachweis der dauerhaftigkeit und
ernsthaftigkeit eines selbst
tötungswillen gestellt werden können
darf hier differenziert werden zwischen
menschen mit schweren oder
fortgeschrittenen erkrankungen
einerseits und völlig gesunden menschen
andererseits alle diese voraussetzungen
sind selbstredend bei kindern und
jugendlichen nicht gegeben mit der
regelung des suizids ist es aber nicht
getan die niederschwelligen zugang zur
palliativmedizin und hospizdiensten ist
umso eher ist der betroffene bereit
seine situation auch ohne suizid zu
ertragen und vor allem bedarf die
suizidprävention ganz allgemein einer
massiven förderung denn eines darf nicht
vergessen werden auch wenn der suizid
nicht strafbar ist so hat auch jeder
suizid schwere auswirkungen auf das
gesamte umfeld und ist immer auch eine
tragödie vielen dank
thomas seitz war dass er es auch
rechtspolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion hat hier in der orientierungs
debatte zum
suizid zur sterbehilfe gesprochen auf
ihn folgt nun petra sitte angst der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
sie steht nun im zentrum und am anfang
des grundgesetzes und aus ihr leitet
sich das selbstbestimmungsrecht des
einzelnen menschen ab und zur würde und
selbstbestimmung gehört das recht das
eigene leben zu beenden
diese entscheidung so das
bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
urteil dem eigenen leben entsprechend
dem eigenen verständnis von
lebensqualität und sinnhaftigkeit der
eigenen existenz ein ende zu setzen
haben wir zu respektieren damit hat das
gericht vor allem die perspektive der
betroffenen aufgenommen es steht also so
mit niemandem zu zu bewerten aus welcher
lebenssituation heraus der wunsch auf
suizidhilfe entstanden ist und hier war
das bundesverfassungsgericht für viele
überraschend klar
würde und selbstbestimmung müssen
ansatzpunkt jeder gesetzlichen regelung
sein der selbstbestimmte tod ist in den
worten des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ein letzter
ausdruck von würde dies ist recht meine
damen und herren muss praktisch aber
auch wahrnehmbar sein daraus ergibt sich
auch dass die hilfe durch dritte
straffrei sein muss wir tragen hier
gemeinsam verantwortung dafür dass
betroffene die möglichkeit finden
umfassend zu den konsequenzen ihrer
entscheidung aufgeklärt und beraten zu
werden sowohl zu rechtlichen als eben
auch zu medizinischen fragen und
schließlich auch zu hilfsangeboten
und alternativen
diese beratung muss fachlich kompetent
sein sie darf keinen druck aufbauen
weder in die eine noch in die andere
richtung und
vor allem musik zugänglich für alle sein
was bedeutet vor diesem hintergrund soll
dann der zugang zu einem humanen vollzug
des suizids auch tatsächlich ermöglicht
werden denn ein recht das sich in der
praxis nicht ausüben lässt ist kein
recht meine damen und herren niemand
hier möchte dass suizidhilfe in einem
kommerziellen rahmen erfolgt aber
hilfe zur wahrnehmung eines rechts darf
nicht unter strafe gestellt werden es
geht schließlich um mehr fürsorge stadt
mehr strafrecht es geht um mehr schutz
statt bevormundung wir können
kommerziellen angeboten den boden
entziehen indem
beratungsangebote unentgeltlich
gestaltet werden und allen zugänglich
sind das heißt
das heißt statt sozialen und
ökonomischen druck soll auch in dieser
letzten phase des lebens solidarität und
achtung geboten werden danke
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin martina
stammen biebrich aus der spd fragt zu
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin in liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr verehrte
bürgerinnen und bürger wenn wir das
thema suizid wenn wir das thema
suizidhilfe sprechen dann tun wir das
oft mit einem ganz bestimmten bild vor
augen
wir stellen uns dann todkranke menschen
vor die durch unendliches leid und kaum
aus haltbare schmerzen schwer gezeichnet
sind
menschen die einfach nicht mehr
weiterleben wollen oder können
menschen die lebt ihr leben nur noch als
belastung und den eigenen tod als
erlösung empfunden
in seinem urteil zur suizidhilfe hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht die rechte
dieser menschen gestärkt
es hat klipp und klar deutlich gemacht
dass jeder mensch das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben hat das hat
auch dieses haus zu respektieren und
deshalb stehen und sitzen wir heute hier
gleichzeitig hat das gericht aber betont
dass ich das selbstbestimmungsrecht über
das eigene leben eben gerade nicht auf
unheilbare krankheitszustände wo der
bestimmte lebens und krankheitsphasen
beschränkt nein es gilt für uns alle
egal ob alt oder jung krank oder gesund
das beispiel des unheilbar kranken ist
deshalb nur ein kleiner ausschnitt der
realität mit der wir jetzt umgehen
müssen diese realität kennt keine
vorgefertigten dem schablonen und diese
realität umfasst menschen die aus den
verschiedensten persönlichen gründen
ihrem leben einem ende ein ende setzen
wollen
es ist nicht unsere aufgabe
werturteile darüber zu fällen weshalb
jemand sein leben beenden möchte es ist
auch nicht die aufgabe dieses hauses
festzulegen wann es akzeptabel ist wenn
jemand sich das leben nehmen möchten
ich warne deshalb entschieden davor dass
ich dieses haus eine bewertung der
individuellen gründe für diese
entscheidung an mast und so bestimmten
menschen ihre rechte vorenthält
wichtig vor allem ist aber folgende wir
müssen vorsorge dafür treffen dass die
frei verantwortlichkeit und die
dauerhaftigkeit des stabi wunsches zu
jeder zeit sichergestellt ist
menschen die sich den tod wünschen
müssen besonders gut vor zwang und
manipulation geschützt werden
es liegt in unserer verantwortung
einen rechtssicheren rahmen hierfür zu
schaffen wir müssen uns durch
entsprechende schutzbestimmungen
verhindern dass die freie
verantwortlichkeit der entscheidung
durch psychischen
gesellschaftlichen oder wirtschaftlichen
druck in frage gestellt wird
gleichzeitig
müssen wir aber auch sicherstellen dass
das recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben
nicht durch blockieren das
verwaltungshandeln eingeschränkt wird es
braucht also einen geregelten prozess
der den menschen die wahrnehmung ihres
rechtes erlaubt
diejenigen einrichtungen in denen
künftig suizidhilfe geleistet werden
wird brauchen wir von uns hier die
entsprechende unterstützung um diese
neue herausforderung gut zu bewältigen
das sind unsere aufgaben nicht mehr und
nicht weniger
klar ist für mich auch dass es dort wo
die frei verantwortlichkeit wie die haft
nicht gewährleistet es etwa bei kindern
oder bei menschen mit rechtlicher
betreuung keine suizidhilfe geben darf
genauso wenig kommt die suizidhilfe bei
patientenverfügungen frage weil die
kontinuität des stabi wunsches so nicht
sichergestellt werden kann
ich will am ende meiner ideen zwei ganz
wichtige punkte ansprechen die wir im
rahmen dieses verfahrens ebenfalls
unbedingt adressieren sollten kollegin
kaputt sondern hat schon getan zum einen
geht es um die stärkung der
suizidprävention und zum anderen um die
stärkung der palliativmedizinischen
versorgung
eine neue regelung der suizidhilfe
sollte beide punkte mit aufnehmen und
von vornherein die zahl der
suizidwilligen personen zu senken ich
weiß dass viele kolleginnen und kollegen
das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes sehr kritisch
sehen dennoch rufe ich sie heute dazu
auf begreifen wir dieses urteil als
chance begreifen wir dieses urteil als
chance dafür einen rahmen zu schaffen
dass er menschen mit frei
verantwortlichen und dauerhaften stapel
wunsch ermöglicht mit würden aus dem
leben zu scheiden vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
der bundestag diskutiert über die
sterbehilfe es gibt schon drei
gesetzentwürfe die werden hier aber noch
nicht beraten sondern nach dieser
orientierungs debatte wird an diesen
entwürfen weitergearbeitet ehesten kann
auch noch neue kommen und dann soll im
sommer eine erste lesung im parlament
abgehalten werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
urteil des bundesverfassungsgericht hat
uns einen auftrag gegeben die frage nach
den gesetzlichen regelungen zur
sterbehilfe hier im deutschen bundestag
zu diskutieren diese grundfrage des
menschlichen daseins berührt mehr als
jede andere die identität und die
individualität in dieser orientierungs
debatte gibt es kein richtig und es gibt
kein falsch es gibt kein schwarz es gibt
kein weiß es gibt kein oben es gibt kein
unten das heißt aber nicht dass diese
entscheidung keine auswirkungen hat
unser grundgesetz baut auf die würde des
menschen auf die in unserem christlichen
menschenbild fest verankert ist dazu
gehört auch dass die freie entscheidung
für selbstbestimmtes sterben von
einzigen von jedem einzelnen getroffen
werden kann bei den gesetzlichen
regelungen kann es aber nicht alleine um
die entscheidung des einzelnen gehen der
gesellschaftliche und der kulturelle
umgang mit dem tod ist prägend für eine
soziale gemeinschaft sterben und tod
sind nicht nur eine privatangelegenheit
sie berühren auch die gesellschaft als
ganzes richtig ist bei dieser debatte
geht es um die zentrale ethischen fragen
für unsere gesellschaft über den umgang
mit dem leben und dem tod daher müssen
wir als gesellschaft die notwendigen
ethischen leitplanken diskutieren und
setzen papst johannes paul der zweite
hat einmal gesagt ich zitiere der tod
zwingt den menschen sich die radikalen
fragen nach dem eigentlichen sinn des
lebens zu stellen
das habe ich ganz persönlich erlebt als
mein vater im jahr 2004 als sie 25 jahre
alt war unheilbar krank an darmkrebs
erkrankt ist und zwei jahre später an
den lebermetastasen verstorben ist
zeitweise waren die schmerzen für ihn
fast nicht zu ertragen vielleicht hat er
sich auch manchmal gedacht es wäre
besser wenn er seinem leben und dem leid
ein ende setzen würde vielleicht hat er
sich gedacht er könnte seiner familie so
das miterleben des leides ersparen aber
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
er hat es nicht getan und er hat mir
etwas wichtiges mitgegeben es gibt nicht
nur schatten und licht nur leid und
glückseligkeit das leben ist viel
facettenreicher
nach der ambulanten chemotherapie gegen
mein vater in die kirche in meiner
heimatstadt in böblingen hat eine kerze
angezündet ging danach in die kneipen
hatten bier getrunken das hat mir
gezeigt er war geprägt vom leid aber er
hat trotzdem noch so viel leben in sich
viele erfahrungen die er mir und meiner
familie damit mitgeben mit gegeben hat
hat mich sehr stark und tief geprägt
unter entwurf den wir heute hier
diskutieren möchte diese freie
entscheidung über das leben und sterben
schützen der staat muss sicherstellen
dass diese umkehrbare entscheidung
unumkehrbare entscheidung frei und ohne
jeden druck getroffen wird wir brauchen
in deutschland daher einen klar
definierten gesetzlichen rahmen nicht
für das selbstbestimmte sterben sondern
zum schutz der selbstständigen
entscheidung über das eigene leben
alte und kranke menschen dürfen nicht
das gefühl haben dass druck auf sie
ausgeübt wird dies zu verhindern ist die
oberste pflicht des staates er schützt
damit das recht auf ein selbstbestimmtes
und würdevolles leben ich bin davon
überzeugt dass es richtig ist so paradox
es auch klingen mag dass bei der frage
des selbstbestimmten scherben zimmer den
schutz des lebens und die würde des
menschen in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
ist das haben wir in unserem
gruppenantrag getan der assistierte
selbstmord darf niemals die normale form
der lebens beendigung werden
insbesondere für alte und kranke
menschen wir haben daher in unserem
gesetzentwurf klar eine regelung im
strafgesetzbuch
vorgesehen die die geschäftsmäßige
förderung von selbsttötung strafbar
lässt den menschen soll nach unserem
entwurf weit reichende hilfsangebote
gemacht werden und werbung für
attestierten selbstmord soll
strafrechtlich verboten werden ich weiß
darüber kann man viel diskutieren und
dafür kann man auch viel hier in diesem
hohen haus streiten aber mir geht es
darum gute rahmenbedingungen eben auch
mit einem und diesem uns vorgesetzten
gesetzentwurf den wir oder den ich hier
mit vertreten möchte deswegen meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen der
mensch steht im mittelpunkt bei dieser
frage und daher würde ich mich freuen
wenn sie unseren gesetzentwurf
unterstützen würden dankeschön
so
markiert aus der cdu/csu-fraktion bei
den gesetzentwürfen handelt es sich
allerdings über
fraktionsübergreifende initiative und
renate künast spricht jetzt ein nächstes
sich die grünen-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
im kern geht es um selbstbestimmung das
ist das was das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes uns
mitgegeben haben das hat im februar 20
klargestellt dass aus dem allgemeinen
persönlichkeitsrecht
quasi als ausdruck persönlicher
autonomie das recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben volk und deshalb auch das recht
sich dazu einer hilfe zu bedienen und
deshalb haben sie den damaligen paragraf
217 für nichtig erklärt den wir hier
auch intensiv diskutiert haben tatsache
ist heute und das sage ich weil einige
gesagt haben das
bundesverfassungsgericht haben uns einen
auftrag gegeben hat es nicht wir könnten
die situation jetzt einfach so lassen
als bundestag weil der 217 ist nichtig
andere dinge sind geregelt tötung auf
verlangen ist strafbar nein meine damen
und herren die frage ist ob wir das
wollen ob wir als bundestag und mühen
wollen dazu einen rahmen zu setzen
schutzregeln einzusetzen war tatsache
ist nach dieser entscheidung findet
beihilfe zur sterbehilfe stadt vereine
beraten ärztinnen und ärzten machen
beihilfe fragen sich wir fragen uns aber
an dieser stelle gibt es eigentlich die
notwendige transparenz welche mittel
verschreiben die da eigentlich meine
damen und herren und dass es für uns für
die gruppe um milch katja keul am franke
frau scherer frau bayram herr bender und
andere ist für uns der punkt zu sagen
wir brauchen eine rechts einheitliche
regelung die im ganzen bundesgebiet geht
wir brauchen
schutzmechanismen an der sparte beratung
zuverlässigkeitsprüfung und eine
transparenz und deshalb sagen wir nein
wir können jetzt nicht sagen die regeln
es nicht wir brauchen eine regelung
es ist aufgabe und wir dürfen uns nicht
dafür drücken und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja übrigens
auch immer klar gesagt man darf nicht
verhindern dass es einen weg gibt in
zumutbarer weise sein leben zu beenden
und deshalb meine damen und herren geht
es hier um die eine frage kriegt man
gute beratung durch vereine nicht
irgendwelche sondern auch zuverlässige
hat man den zugang zu betäubungsmittel
zb pentobarbital bei dem auch
palliativmedizinern mediziner sagen dass
es dann eigentlich der zumutbare und
geeignete weg starb ein zu haben bei dem
sie möglicherweise reflexartig sich noch
erbrechen obwohl sie sterben wollen und
am ende mit schweren behinderungen da
liegen meine damen und herren das ist
nicht würdevoll und wir alle haben eins
die aufgabe es bleibt uns gar nichts
anderes übrig als die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgericht zu respektieren
jeder mensch hat das recht in jeder
lebensphase wir meinen wenn man jetzt an
die frage geht wie regelt man dass man
sollte es jetzt nicht zu schwer machen
deshalb kritisch auf dem blick mit einer
strafvorschrift zu beginn die als erstes
sagt drei jahre freiheitsstrafe wir
meinen aber auch man sollte es nicht zu
leicht machen bei manchen bereichen
vielleicht können wir auch nicht alles
millimetergenau regeln liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen in manchen bereichen ist es
schwierig wir haben zum beispiel gesagt
volljährige sollen den zugang haben
warum den diskutieren gerne im ausschuss
dann noch drüber aber ab welchem alter
ist jemand in der pubertät trotzdem vom
freiem willen beseelt und kann danach
handeln was ist mit der entscheidung der
eltern oder familiengericht wie stehen
die drei zu einander
schwierig meine damen und herren aber
auf alle fälle nicht zu schwer durch
strafgesetzbuch sich nicht zu einfach
machen meine damen und herren und
natürlich wir haben nicht das recht
materielle kriterien aufzustellen wir
können verfahrensvorschriften machen und
sagen wir müssen sehen dass es
freiwillig ist ein freier wille und die
fähigkeit danach zu handeln und dann
müssen wir dem weg zur bar eröffnen
meine damen und herren und dieser weg
muss heißen schutzvorschriften
transparenzvorschriften zuverlässigkeit
in dem verein beratungs
beratungsfristen zwischen zwei beratung
meine damen und herren und aufklärung
über wirkungsweisen das ethische dach
für uns ist wir haben es im para vier
unseres gesetzesentwurfes formuliert
nämlich ausdrücklich der grundwert jedes
menschenlebens das ist sozusagen der
ethische punkt und ich will einmal an
dieser stelle konkret werden wie wir es
regeln möchten meine damen und herren
wir haben uns gesagt für volljährige
habe ich gesagt und wir machen jetzt
zwei wege unser vorschlag ist zwei wege
zu machen die wir für adäquater im weg 1
ist die voraussetzung für den zugang zu
und betäubungsmitteln für sterbewillige
in medizinische notlage wir stellen uns
vor dass jemand in existenzieller not
luftnot ist den kann ich nicht noch
irgendwohin schicken sondern für den die
person ermöglichen wir und wollen wir
ermöglichen den weg an der stelle mit
den behandelten ärztin oder arzt das
gespräch zu führen mit regeln wie das
schriftlich darzulegen ist mit
aufklärungs dokumentationspflichten mit
einem zweiten arzt oder einer ärztin die
unabhängig davon sagen sagen muss dass
dieser freie wille vorliegt und
aufgeklärt wurde meine damen und herren
ich glaube dass das angemessen ist zumal
in diesem punkt wir beides haben nämlich
auch die beratung vielleicht über eine
schmerztherapie und der andere weg meine
damen und herren ist bei uns der zugang
für in allen anderen fällen wo wir sagen
es muss eine behörde geben wie er
gegenüber mainz man sein sterbewunsch
glaubhaft darlegt die dauer darlegt und
ein zwei fragen beantwortet das fazit
meine damen und herren ist wir wissen
wir müssen nicht wir können regeln einen
schutz vorschrift machen dann sollten
wir sie auch tun und
für meine begriffe ist es so dass wir
den weg gehen sollten dass sie einen die
ärzte des vertrauens kontaktieren können
die anderen einen offenen zugang haben
und neben allen meine damen und herren
würde ich sagen was wir wirklich
sträflich vernachlässigt haben ist die
gesamte bereich der flächendeckenden
guten versorgung am palliativ und
hospizversorgung
dieser gelegenheit ändern
sagt renate künast nächster redner ist
benjamin strasser ist zwar
parlamentarische staatssekretär beim
justizministerium allerdings spricht er
heute nicht in dieser funktion sondern
wie die anderen auch als abgeordneter
auch er hat sich an einem gesetzentwurf
beteiligt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seinem
urteil aus dem februar 2020 für klarheit
gesorgt klar ist dass eine jahrelange
debatte um das ob des assistierten
suizids beendet ist wir diskutieren
jetzt über das wie und klar ist auch
dass das urteil einen regelungs losen
zustand hinterlassen hat mit dem viele
abgesehen von manchen sterbehilfen
verein unzufrieden sind und ja das ist
eine schwierige aufgabe für uns als
gesetzgeber das ist sicher keiner leicht
macht für mich ist aber auch klar nichts
tun kann keine option sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber auch
den rahmen des diskurses verschoben im
kern steht jetzt die frage wie sichern
wir tatsächlich
selbstbestimmung für alle menschen in
allen lebenslagen es geht eben nicht
mehr nur um schwerstkranke menschen in
der letzten phase ihres lebens es geht
auch um menschen mit einer
suchterkrankung psychischen erkrankungen
es geht um menschen mit behinderungen es
geht um menschen die in armut leben und
ja es geht auch um menschen die
pflegebedürftig werden und die sich die
frage stellen investiere ich mein geld
und teile meines geldes in einem
pflegeplatz oder gebe ich es meinen
kindern und enkelkindern und gerade
dieses beispiel ist nicht konstruiert
sondern die ängste die befürchtungen sie
sind messbar so wollen laut einer studie
mit dem titel 55plus pflege im alter
74 der bürgerinnen und bürger bei einem
pflegefall ihren kindern nicht zur last
fallen und die gespräche die wir in den
letzten zwei jahren geführt haben mit
ärztinnen und ärzten mit stern.de
begleiterinnen und begleiter die decken
sich mit dieser studienlage und deswegen
müssen wir auch anerkennen dass
nicht jeder sterbewunsch ein suizid
wunsch ist die äußerung von betroffenen
ich will nicht mehr leben ist wenn man
sich mit diesem wunsch auseinander satz
mit ihnen spricht oftmals eben
eigentlich als ich will so nicht mehr
leben gemacht und deswegen wenn ihr
selbstbestimmung anstehen dann müssen
wir diese schwierige entscheidung
absichern wir müssen sie ab sicherlich
eine umfassende beratung über die
alternativen des assistierten suizids
wir müssen sie absichern dadurch dass
die alternativen zum suizid tatsächlich
auch zeitnah verfügbar sind und ja wir
müssen sie auch absichern dadurch dass
eine unzulässige beeinflussung durch
dritte in dieser heiklen phase
bestmöglich ausgeschlossen ist und dazu
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht uns
eben auch den weg weiterhin offen
gelassene generalpräventiven wirkung des
strafrechts es geht hier nicht um
bevormundung es geht nicht um
kriminalisierung sondern es geht darum
dass das schutzkonzept über die
selbstbestimmung nicht nur im
bundesgesetzblatt steht sondern der
praxis tatsächlich gelebt wird
soweit die rede von benjamin strasser
hier in dieser orientierungs debatte
nächster redner ist martin sichert erst
aus gesundheitspolitischer sprecher der
fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
in den letzten zwei jahren würde bei
nahezu jeder gesundheitspolitischen
debatte so getan als geld da ist jedes
leben um jeden preis zu erhalten und
heute nun diskutieren wir darüber wie
der staat menschen dabei helfen sollte
ihr leben zu beenden
obwohl es 2020 eine deutliche
unterschiedlichkeit gab wurden millionen
psychisch kranke zehntausende
krebskranke und zehntausende mit
schweren nebenwirkungen in kauf genommen
um zu versuchen zu verhindern dass auch
nur ein weiterer mensch als corona tote
meer stirbt nun also diskutieren wir
hier über sterbehilfe und ich fand es
sehr interessant zu beobachten dass
einige der befürworter schärfster corona
maßnahme mit all den damit verbundenen
gesundheitsschäden sich nun für
weitreichende sterbehilfe aussprechen
zwei jahre wurden würde und
selbstbestimmung mit füßen getreten ist
freut mich sehr dass hier und heute nun
viele würde und selbstbestimmung in den
vordergrund stellen und ich wünsche mir
dass das künftig auch bei allen anderen
themen so sein wird
es muss klar sein dass sterbehilfe
anders als corona nicht zum
geschäftsmodell mit milliardengewinnen
für pharma- und ärzte werden darf es
muss sichergestellt werden dass niemand
besser verdient wenn sich am ende einer
beratung jemand für den tod entscheidet
als wenn derjenige sich für das leben
entscheidet und die entscheidung über
sterbehilfe sollte nur derjenige selbst
treffen können aber man sollte eine
möglichkeit einräumen durch die der
mensch in einer patientenverfügung
bestimmte parameter festlegen kann wann
er sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen möchte
wenn jemand bei vollem bewusstsein eine
verfügung formuliert dass er wenn er
massive schmerzen hat und beispielsweise
nach einem schlaganfall nicht mehr
seinen willen klar formulieren kann der
sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen möchte
warum sollte man es ihm verwehren
grundsätzlich sollte sterbehilfe aber
eng begrenzt sein wer unheilbar krank
ist der starke schmerzen hat und leidet
der sollte das recht haben sein leiden
zu beenden und dabei auch unterstützung
finden das ist menschlich bei schweren
leiden muss das auch ohne lange
wartezeiten möglich seien auch bei
menschen bei denen man weiß dass die
beendigung lebenserhaltender maßnahmen
mit leid verbunden sind weil die
menschen schmerzen haben oder das
sterben sich tage lang hinzieht bis der
mensch elendig erstickt oder verdurstet
ist sollte es die möglichkeit geben mit
der spritze dem leid ein schnelles ende
zu setzen aber gesunden menschen dabei
zu helfen sich aus dem leben zu
befördern nur weil diese lebensmüde sind
das ist nicht aufgabe des staates das
hat auch der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte in seinem urteil vom 12
april dieses jahres festgestellt in dem
erklärt wurde dass es kein
grundsätzliches recht auf beihilfe zum
suizid gibt und das sollten wir alle
auch bedenken wenn wir uns um die
entsprechenden anträge vielen dank
der kollege
martin sichert war dass ich habe eben
schon gesagt sprecher für
gesundheitspolitik und auch die nächste
rednerin hat diese funktion inne kathrin
vogler für die linksfraktion
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin sehr froh zu hören ist zumindest
in den demokratischen parteien noch
einen konsens gibt dass es grenzen gibt
dass es zum beispiel die tötung auf
verlangen in keinem der bisher
vorliegenden gesetzentwürfe legalisiert
werden soll denn ich finde wir müssen
darauf achten gerade wenn wir über
dieses sensible thema reden dass wir
grenzen waren und dass wir auch nicht
unterscheiden zwischen menschen die
krank sind die psychisch krank sind die
behindert sind oder menschen die gesund
sind das erweckt doch das würde doch
erwecken ganz schlimme erinnerungen an
die geschichte dieses landes und auch da
bin ich froh dass wir uns sehr breit
hier in diesem hause auf der
demokratischen seite einig sind wir
reden heute darüber wie wir verhindern
können dass menschen die sich
entschieden haben ihr leben zu beenden
und durch ein angeboten angebots
getriebenes marktsystem dazu gedrängt
werden könnten und wie sie angemessen
unterstützung und beratung und damit
einen weg aus ihrer lebenskrise finden
können und wenn wir darüber sprechen
dann müssen wir uns auch über die
realität der mangelhaften
suizidprävention in diesem land
unterhalten in dem sich jeden tag etwa
25 menschen das leben nehmen und deshalb
schlägt die gruppe der die ich
unterstütze mit frau kaputt gonther und
herrn castellucci herrn heveling und
anderen auch vor dass wir ein gesetz zur
suizidprävention
schaffen das fordern auch viele verbände
und institutionen die menschen mit
psychischen erkrankungen mit behinderung
oder pflegebedarf vertreten und die sich
mit den sozialen nöten von menschen in
zeiten immer ungleiche
lebensverhältnisse und zunehmender
existenzsorgen beschäftigen und ich lade
sie ein beteiligen sie sich darin lassen
sie uns egal welchen gesetzentwurfs sie
bevorzugen dieses thema in den
mittelpunkt stellen märz für
suizidprävention in diesem land
auch lars castellucci der nächster
redner hat sich hier mit einem vorschlag
beteiligt im vorfeld hat er auch schon
gesagt er wolle den assistierten suizid
ermöglichen ihnen aber nicht fördern und
herren
warum ist der suizid oder der
assistierte suizid
eigentlich die klare ausnahme in unserer
gesellschaft hat das etwas mit tradition
zu tun oder mit tabus oder mit
mangelndem zugang
ich glaube ganz entscheidend für die
allermeisten menschen ist ihr
lebenswille
lebenswille gerade wenn es auf das
sterben zugeht hoffnung es könnte noch
rettung geben noch erleben dass der
enkel zur welt kommt und deshalb ja ich
bin der meinung dass wir den sterbe
willen und in dieser konsequenz auch den
suizid wilden von menschen anerkennen
müssen aber viel mehr bin ich der
meinung dass sie ihren lebenswillen
unterstützen müssen so lange und mit
allem was uns möglich ist
es kann ihnen leben immer wieder
situationen geben in denen unser
lebenswille wie verschüttet ist krisen
gesundheitlich zeiten der trauer
depressive phasen und dann können auch
suizid gedanken kommen und sie sind und
es hat kersten cup abgesagt ebenso
benjamin strasser sie sind eben in den
allermeisten fällen nicht mit einem
sterbewunsch verbunden sondern mit dem
wunsch nicht so leben zu müssen wie er
sich aktuell darstellt wir geben viel
geld für forschung aus in diesem bereich
die ergebnisse dieser forschung sind
eindeutig wir sollten sie jetzt in
diesem gesetzgebungsverfahren
berücksichtigen
und deswegen müsste unsere platte
korrekter weise auch suizidhilfe heißen
und nicht sterbehilfe denn ein suizid
wurde es eben nicht automatisch mit
einem sterbewunsch gleichzusetzen
also geht es in den allermeisten fällen
auch nicht vorschnell darum
möglichkeiten des sterbens aufzuzeigen
sondern hilfe und unterstützung im leben
anzubieten und ich will das als
organisationen die sich vielleicht eine
schwäche eine momentane schwäche eines
menschen zunutze machen und einen weg
zum schnellen tod versprechen wie wir
das sicher stellen darum geht es in den
kommenden beratungen und eines ist für
mich klar frau helling klar mit
flächendeckenden staatlich finanzierten
suizid beratungsstellen erreichen wir
das genaue gegenteil was es braucht sind
dagegen flächendeckende
beratungsangebote zur ganzen vielfalt
menschlicher problemlagen ausreichende
therapieplätze arbeitsbedingungen in
heimen in krankenhäuser in dem die
beschäftigten zeit für die menschen
haben daran dürfen wir nicht nachlassen
zu arbeiten
und ja es bleiben die fälle in denen
jemand ob schwer erkrankt oder nicht
jung oder alt für sich selber
entscheidet das war es jetzt
und dafür auch die selbsttötung die
hilfe anderer menschen erbittet diese
freie entscheidung steht den menschen zu
sie kann bedauert werden
aber sie muss auch respektiert werden
und
dafür müssen wir regelung schaffen die
ärzteschaft hat das mit ihrem
standesrecht bereits getan jetzt sind
wir als gesetzgeber gefordert und müssen
regeln unter welchen umständen die
abgabe eines todbringenden medikamentes
nach dem betäubungsmittelgesetz erlaubt
werden kann
so richtig es ist diesen assistierten
suizid zu ermöglichen so richtig ist es
allerdings einer normalisierung des
suizids entgegen zu locken
warum
weil dann auch die gefahr für die
selbstbestimmung von menschen droht weil
dann der druck steigt dass sich menschen
zu fragen bedingen lohnt sich das noch
völlig nicht nur zu last was koste ich
und diese fragen verlangen nach der
gegenrede denn niemand in diesem land
soll sich überflüssig fühlen wir wollen
ein gutes land für alle sein und
deswegen friedlich sie gehen sie uns im
weg mit den assistierten suizid zu
ermöglichen ohne ihn zu fördern ich
bitte sie um ihre unterstützung vielen
dank
ich sagen dass die kollegen thomas
rachel cdu csu fraktion thomas rachel
ist in seiner fraktion sprecher für
kirchen und religionsgemeinschaften
bürger der präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die menschen werden älter
das ist eine gute nachricht aber
zugleich wächst bei vielen von ihnen die
angst dass sie im alter oder bei
krankheit allein sind oder leiden viele
von ihnen wollen niemandem zur last
fallen
meine damen und herren ist es nicht die
erste debatte die wir zur frage der
sterbehilfe führen und das ist gut so
denn es lenkt unseren blick auf den
menschen und zwar gerade auf den
menschen in seiner verletzlichkeit
vielleicht sogar in seiner
vermeintlichen ausweglosigkeit das macht
mich zuallererst und vor allem demütig
da steht im zentrum unserer bemühungen
der schwerst leidende mensch selbst
soziales handeln ist aus sicht des
christlichen menschenbildes immer
zutiefst zu bedauern und tragisch aus
guten ethischen gründen haben wir uns
2014 zusammen mit den beiden großen
christlichen kirchen gegen die
organisierte und geschäftsmäßige
beihilfe zum suizid ausgesprochen der
suizid seien ethisch wie auch politisch
letztlich nicht vollständig
regulierbarer grenzfall menschlicher
existenz
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat dem
gesetzgeber allerdings auf geforderten
gesetzlichen neuregelungen für den
assistierten suizid zu schaffen die
sorgen vieler nehme ich sehr ernst denen
dieses urteil zu weit geht besonders
hinsichtlich der schrankenlosen
möglichkeit zum assistierten suizid auch
in fällen ohne schwere oder
lebensbedrohlichen krankheitsverlauf
wir müssen die grund vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichts beachten dabei
gibt es ermessensspielräume die wir als
wertegebundene gesetzgeber ausfüllen
sollten es darf gesellschaftlich nicht
zur normalität werden sich das leben zu
nehmen oder anderen dabei zu helfen
ich glaube dass ein ganz wichtiger punkt
den wir bei der anstehenden gesetzgebung
zwingend berücksichtigen müssen es muss
sichergestellt werden dass menschen
nicht unter einen zusätzlichen druck
geraten jede form der kommerzialisierung
der suizidbeihilfe muss ausgeschlossen
werden genauso wie jede werbung
sehr geehrte damen und herren ein
ermutigendes zeichen im sinne der
ökumene ist die gemeinsame stellungnahme
der katholischen bischöfe und der
evangelischen leitenden geistlichen in
niedersachsen und bremen zur
suizidbeihilfe sie erinnert daran dass
eine gesetzliche regelung für einen
angemessenen umgang mit konkreten
grenzsituationen zwischen leben und tod
letztlich nicht ausreichen sondern jeder
einzelfall multi perspektivisch
betrachtet werden muss
die unterstützung eines suizids sie ist
und bleibt eine gewissensentscheidung in
einer grenz und in einer notsituation
insofern kann auch weder eine person
noch eine institution zur suizidbeihilfe
verpflichtet werden
ob beihilfe zum suizid in grenzen
notsituationen in kirchlichen häusern
geduldet werden solle sei nicht pauschal
zu beantworten
sondern müsse im einzelfall geklärt
werden schreiben zb die christlichen
kirchen in niedersachsen
neben der selbstbestimmung des
suizidwilligen muss auch die
verantwortung für die angehörigen und
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
den einrichtungen mit bedacht werden
diese einzeln abwägungen wollen uns
sollten wir ebenfalls ausreichend raum
geben
unser ganzes bemühen sollte sich aber
vornehmlich auf das eigentliche ziel
konzentrieren nämlich leiden und
schmerzen nach menschen möglichkeit zu
mindern persönliche fürsorge seelsorge
und begleitung zu leisten und die beste
palliativmedizinische und hospizliche
versorgung für alle sicherzustellen
daher brauchen wir als erstes ein gesetz
zum massiven ausbau von niedrig stellen
niedrigschwelligen angeboten zur
suizidprävention
wir brauchen fachlich kompetente und
menschlich zugerannt
zugewandte hospizarbeit und
palliativversorgung für schwer kranke
patient innen entscheidend ist es ein
menschenwürdiges leben auch in der
letzten lebensphase sicher zu stellen
denn wir möchten erreichen dass ein
mensch nicht durch die hand eines
anderen sondern an der hand eines
anderen verstört herzlichen dank
thomas rachel hat hier noch mal in
seiner rede darauf hingewiesen dass es
weder zu einer kommerzialisierung der
des assistierten suizids kommen darf
noch zu einer verpflichtung von ärzten
und institutionen diese durchzuführen
till steffen grüne stolz ich die wahl
gegangen
wir sind heute hier weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht vor gut zwei
jahren eine richtungsweisende
entscheidung getroffen hat und zwar
das allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht
umfasst eben auch das recht zu
entscheiden wann das leben zu ende sein
soll es erklärte dass im strafgesetzbuch
renommierte verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
förderung der selbsttötung als nichtig
weil es die möglichkeiten einer
assistierte selbsttötung
faktisch weitgehend entleerte
daraus ergibt sich für uns als
gesetzgeber die aufgabe sicherzustellen
dass ein zugang zu freiwillig bereit
suizidhilfe real gegeben ist das ist
eine schwierige aufgabe da sie auf
höchst persönliche erfahrung ansichten
wertvorstellungen trifft ich denke
jedoch dass die meisten von uns wir
haben es eben gesehen in wesentlichen
punkten übereinstimmen bei dem gefühl an
eine geschäftsmäßig betrieben
suizidhilfe beschleicht uns alle ein
ungutes gefühl
wir haben die sicherlich nicht
unberechtigte sorge dass die
selbsttötung normalisiert wird und ist
daher zu einem anstieg kommt und ganz
besonders besorgt dass uns dass sich
ältere und jüngere menschen auch von
ihrem engsten umfeld zu einer beendigung
ihres lebens gedrängt fühlen können es
stellt sich daher die frage wie wir
diese widersprechenden interessen am
besten zum ausgleich bringen können ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass der
wichtigste baustein auf diesem weg eine
neutrale und ergebnisoffene beratung ist
und dies ist der weg den unser
gesetzentwurf capri allen klar petra
sitte hecken sind empfehlen gesprochen
denn dieser gesetzentwurf beschreitet
wir wollen dass jeder mensch der sich
mit dem gedanken eine selbsttötung trägt
umfassend informiert wird über die
bedeutung und folgen für ihn und sein
persönliches umfeld über die
voraussetzung und am wichtigsten über
alternativen gibt es nie schaffen eine
beratungs infrastruktur nötig die für
alle leicht zugelegt ist diese beratung
die muss ergebnisoffen erfolgen die
beratung soll aber auch sicherstellen
dass betroffenen etwa bei vorliegen von
akuten psychischen störungen die
möglichkeit der inanspruchnahme weitere
hilfsangebote eröffnet wird die beratung
ist die notwendige voraussetzung nach
unserem entwurf um eine ärztliche
verschreibung eines medikaments zur
selbsttötung zu erhalten ein arzt darf
einer person die aus autonomen frei
gebildeten willen ihr leben beenden
möchte dann ein arzneimittel zum zwecke
der selbsttötung verschreiben wobei er
dann auch noch zu umfassender aufklärung
verpflichteten ist dieses verfahren
sagen eine geschäftsmäßige suizidhilfe
eben nicht fördern sondern überflüssig
machen das ist das ziel dieses gesetz
sind tatsächlich ist es so dass allein
die möglichkeit suizidhilfe in anspruch
zu nehmen bei nicht wenigen
suizidwilligen dem effekt hat von einem
solchen abzusehen ich möchte nicht dass
wie es ein anderer entwurf vorsieht
ärzte letztlich entscheiden ob ein
absehbar nicht mehr veränderlicher
sterbewunsch vorliegt oder nicht auch
könnte die auswahl von ärzten durch
angehörige manipuliert werden und können
wir es ärzten zumuten diese entscheidung
zu treffen ich habe da sorgen zudem
differenziert der entwurf zwischen
sterbewilligen in einer gegenwärtigen
medizinische notlage und anderen
sterbewilligen ich halte diese
abgrenzung für ausgesprochen schwierig
worauf soll abgestellt werden etwa auf
starke schmerzen dass es weitgehend
überholt weil sie sind heutzutage
praktisch alle behandelbar und dann ist
ja die frage was es bei der nicht schwer
kranken oder soll eine staplerhersteller
eine prüfung vornehmen was hat der staat
eigentlich an der stelle zu suchen ich
finde da gehört er nicht hin und
deswegen möchte ich auch nicht dass
menschen dann dieser situation einer
solchen prüfung ausgesetzt sind und der
dritte entwurf der möchte den weg gehen
über strafgesetzbuch das ist nach meiner
ganz festen überzeugung nicht die
richtige stelle für dieses thema die
suizidhilfe hier umfassend zu regeln
enthält eine sehr klare wertung die nach
meiner überzeugung mit der entscheidung
des bundesverfassungsgerichts eben nicht
in einklang steht sie sagt die stört
mich diese entscheidung und ich bin mit
der entscheidung nicht einverstanden und
deswegen ging trotzdem im grunde den
gleichen weg den das
bundesverfassungsgericht verworfen hat
und wir müssen uns dieser aufgabe
stellen dass dieser weg durch das
gericht verbaut worden ist
meine damen und herren das grundgesetz
garantiert ein recht auf leben es
begründet aber keine pflicht zum leben
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat klar
gestellt dass das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht das recht umfasst
zu entscheiden wann das leben zu ende
sein soll an diesem anspruch orientiert
sich unser gesetzentwurf wir möchten
sicherstellen dass der mensch bei aller
notwendigen unterstützung seien
nachhaltig und autonom gebildeten freien
willen nicht mehr leben zu wollen
umsetzen kann dann herzlichen
[Applaus]
als nächstes zählt das wort der kollege
michael kruse fdp fraktion
sagte präsident meine geschätzten
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst einmal
wir führen ja eine debatte unter
aufhebung des
fraktionszwangs für ein thema wieder
sterbehilfe ist das sehr angemessen
dieses verfahren zwingt jeden einzelnen
in diesem raum und jeder einzelne sich
selbst eine eigene haltung zu diesem
thema zu bilden und das ist aus meiner
sicht der entscheidende vorteil der
heutigen debatte und des formats und
deswegen begrüße ich das sehr wir haben
heute viele rechtliche und moralische
aspekte gehört zur korrekten
ausgestaltung der sterbehilfe ich
persönlich habe mich für den antrag der
kollegin kathrin helling klar dr till
steffen und vielen weiteren otto fricke
entschieden weil ich meine das ist der
antrag ist der der zielstellung die hier
schon oft jetzt rezitiert worden ist am
nächsten kommt nämlich der
freiheit zu einem
selbstbestimmten tod freiheit in allen
lebenslagen aber eben auch freiheit und
selbstbestimmung für das ende des
eigenen lebens und ich möchte nicht all
die argumente wiederholen die jetzt
schon mehrfach vorgetragen worden sind
sondern von der person erzählen mit der
ich die meisten gespräch über dieses
thema geführt habe das ist meine
großmutter meine großmutter wird am
sonntag 100 jahre alt sie lebt
selbstständig sie lebt allein sie
schreibt mit mir whatsapp kurz vor der
sitzung noch zu diesem thema machen
können und sie ist die person die der
ich mich in diesem thema besonders
verpflichtet fühle weil wir seit vielen
jahren darüber brechen weil wir über
hohes alter sprechen weil wir darüber
sprechen was es bedeutet wenn der eigene
lebenswille langsam schwindet und
einsatz den sie sehr häufig zu mir
gesagt hat ist ich habe mein leben
gelebt und wenn ich einmal weggetreten
bin dann helft mir bitte beim sterben
und deswegen weiß ich dass
für
diejenigen die angehörige sind die im
umfeld einer person sind die sich in
diese richtung entscheidet eine hohe
verantwortung besteht dieser hohen
verantwortung versuchen wir mit diesem
vorschlag gerecht zu werden ich habe sie
auch gefragt was sind eigentlich
wären deine wünsche wenn es denn mal so
weit ist sie hat mir gesagt dass sie
sich vor allem wünscht dass es wenig
bürokratie in diesem bereich gibt es
einen niedrigschwelligen zugang gibt
dass es keinen missbrauch geben soll und
dass ihr hilfe
zuteil wird wenn der lebenswille wir
werden am sonntag ihren hundertsten
geburtstag feiern aber ich weiß auch
dass wenn es einmal so weit sein sollte
dass ihr lebenswille erlischt ich eine
hohe verantwortung dafür trage ihren
willen nachzukommen
vielen dank
michael kruse war das nächste rednerin
ist beatrix von storch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wenn wir alt und krank sind unsere
geistigen und körperlichen kräfte finden
verliert unser leben nicht sinn und
würde der schriftsteller walter jens war
ein vehementer kämpfer für die aktive
sterbehilfe und ließ später an schwerer
demenz der gesunde weiter jens konnte
sich nicht vorstellen dass ein solches
leben für ihn noch lebenswert sein
könnte der an schwerer demenz erkrankte
walter jens wollte dann nicht mehr
sterben sondern leben trotz seiner
patientenverfügung das bezeugten die
menschen die ihn am meisten litten und
am besten kannte seine frau und sein
sohn und sie ließen ihn leben das urteil
des verfassungsgerichtes den 2017 das
verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
suizidbeihilfe abzuschaffen hat uns auf
eine schiefe bahn gebracht
minderjährige unter 18 dürfen keine
zigaretten kaufen weil teils gefährdend
aber nach dem diskussionspapier des bmg
seite 17 zu 2 1 a 15 jährige sollen
einen selbstbestimmten entschluss zur
selbsttötung treffen können wenn ein
familiengericht die einsicht und
urteilsfähigkeit feststellt wirklich
zigaretten gefährlich aber selbsttötung
möglich
die forderungen nach aktiver sterbehilfe
wird lauter und ich fürchte
wonach suizidbeihilfe
sterbehilfe zur normalität wird
dafür fließen dann auch irgendwann die
grenzen zwischen tötung auf verlangen
und dann auch tötung ohne verlangen die
niederlande sind ein warnendes beispiel
der medizinethiker theo
hat dort festgestellt dass sich seit der
legalisierung der sterbehilfe der
extreme ausnahmefall zum normalfall
entwickelt hat 4 prozent aller
sterbefälle dort sind sterbehilfe ein
drittel so viel wie krone tote an und
mit corona und zehnmal mehr als
verkehrstote 2020 in den niederlanden
2007 1000 menschen in deutschland wären
das 30.000 in
235 fällen war grund
altersbeschwerden das nachlassen der
sehkraft des gehörs arthritis
gehbeschwerden und den 170 fällen war
der grund demenz meine damen und herren
im niederlanden ist es zulässig schwer
demenzkranke patienten auch dann zu
töten wenn sie sich verbal heftig non
verbal heftig versuchen dagegen zu
wehren
stärken wir die palliativmedizin schon
oft gesagt helfen wir dass menschen an
der hand eines menschen aber nicht durch
die hand eines menschen sterben
ich darf zum schluss die deutsche
bischofskonferenz zitieren von 1999 die
schrieb dazu jeder mensch hat seine
würde sein wert und sein lebensrecht von
gott her weil gott allein herr über
leben und tod ist sind menschenwürde und
leben geschützt daran glaube ich vielen
dank
gegen deinen körper von storch
[Applaus]
das wort hat nun der lina share funktion
ist wie die
[Applaus]
saga herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
mich hat doch jetzt nochmal
aufgeschreckt dieser satz
es darf nicht zur normalität werden denn
herr thomas rachel könnte gerade genannt
hat es darf nicht zur normalität werden
dass man das vielleicht geneigt zunächst
zu sagen okay normalität und sterben das
wollen wir nicht zusammen denken aber in
normalität steckt auch norm es steckt
auch geregelt hat es deckt auch etwas
was wir als selbstverständnis haben in
unserer gesellschaft und der tod und
auch das selbstbestimmte ausscheiden aus
dem leben gehört zur normalität das ist
norm und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht letztendlich
auch normiert indem es unser grundgesetz
ausgelegt hat in der frage was
selbstbestimmtheit heißt in der frage
des aus dem leben scheiden und hat eben
mit klaren kriterien formuliert wann ein
recht zum selbstbestimmten sterben und
damit natürlich impliziert auch
sterbehilfe zuzubilligen ist nämlich
nämlich wenn es sich um einen autonomen
und einen dauerhaften und ernsthaften
willen meldet das sind die festen
kriterien an denen wir uns zu
orientieren haben und ich habe große
demut und auch gar furcht vor dieser
aufgabe dass wir uns hier ein enorm gebo
auf dieser basis auf diesen kriterien
neu widmen und zwar insofern als das ist
natürlich immer und ganz existenzielle
individuelle situationen geht bei denen
dieses recht was wir dann neu zu
schaffen hätten zur anwendung kämen
individuelle entscheidungen die wir
nicht zu entscheiden haben die sind
individuell zu entscheiden wir können
nur den rahmen setzen um diesen recht
dass das verfassungsrecht verbrieft habt
geltung zu verleihen wenn wir jetzt aber
eine weitere runde im bundestag drehen
mit einer gesetzgebung die das
bundesverfassungsgericht für nichtig
erklärt also den boden entzieht zuvor
eine kriminalisierung von
sterbehilfe stattgefunden hat sie war im
gesetz dann hat das eine ist es eine
ausgangs grundlage verdient respekt ab
weil ich anders vermeiden möchte dass
sie erneut eine situation kommen einen
rahmen zu schaffen der wieder
rechtsunsicherheit bringen könnte
vorsorge dass eine nichtigkeit
herauskommt und der kriminalisierung
schaffen könnte und er eben in der
diskussion darüber was denn eigentlich
an legalisierter staatshilfe existiert
und was nicht bedeuten könnte dass sich
die menschen dem wieder nicht widmen
möchten und alles in die tabu-zone
schieben es darf eben dann doch nicht zu
normen als daum gelten was aber doch
normalität ist es ist normalität wir
können das nicht wegleugnen dass es
menschen gibt die selbstbestimmte
sterben wollen die müssen wir uns
solidarisch mit diesen menschen stellen
diesen umständen müssen wir uns stellen
und insofern ist es konsequent
dass wir wenn wir uns als gesetzgeber
dieser frage widmen
uns in dieser einzelfall orientierte
bitten das heißt also auch dass ein
straftatbestand nicht in betracht kommen
kann denn das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat den regelfall definiert der
regelfall ist die erlaubnis wenn wir
jetzt einen straftatbestand mit dem
ausnahmefall der erlaubnis schaffen
würde würden wir dies den den die
aussage des bundesverfassungsgerichts
auf den kopf stellen die rede der
regelfall ist nach dem
bundesverfassungsgericht die erlaubnis
nicht so werde es ist wichtig und das
ist auch in dem antrag
kreuth künast dem ich mich auch
angeschlossen verbrieft darf man mit dem
beratungs ein beratungs rahmen
herausfindet welche individuellen fälle
sind bei
welchem individuellen sind mit autonomen
ernsthaft und dauerhaft angesprochen das
müssen wir identifizieren
ich hoffe wir kommen zu einer guten
lösung in diesem sinne meine zeit ist
abgelaufen vielen
dank
das wort hat nunmehr stolper frage der
kollege hubert hüppe cdu csu fraktion
der präsident vertritt kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
auch gerade nach dieser rede muss ich
sagen dass es mir noch nie so schwer
gefallen ist eine entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
zu akzeptieren wie diese die dort
gefallen ist und ich will sie begründen
denn es zwingt mich an einer regelung
mitzuwirken die ich von meinem gewissen
her grundsätzlich eigentlich nicht nur
eigentlich ablehnen muss
und das ist nicht deswegen weil ich
nicht verstehen kann wenn menschen sich
das leben nehmen worden ich schließe das
übrigens für mich auch nicht aus ob ich
nie in einer solchen situation kommen
könnte aber ich möchte einfach nicht
dass eine regelung kommt die dass die
beihilfe zur selbsttötung sozusagen als
therapeutische alternative sieht das
möchte ich verhindern und meine damen
und herren die meisten menschen die sich
selbst töten sind depressiv alt oder
behindert chronisch krank
pflegebedürftig verwitwet arbeitslos
oder einsam und die suizidforschung
weist darauf hin dass hinter vier und
suizidversuchen eine psychische
erkrankung oder sozialer probleme stehen
und die wenigsten menschen die nach
einem suizidversuch professionelle hilfe
erhalten machen jemand wieder einen
suizid versucht und wir beobachten
dass die debatte um die beihilfe zur
selbsttötung verschärft wurde seit
unsere gesellschaft älter wird und wir
führen sie auch auf dem hintergrund dass
wir überall über pflegenotstand
pflegende und fehlende hilfe
insbesondere in einrichtungen reden
meine damen und herren pflegende oder
menschen die gepflegt werden müssten in
einrichtung deren entscheidung kann auch
sehr wohl beeinflusst werden dadurch wie
die umstände in einer einrichtung sind
und wenn s
und wenn es ein gesetzlich garantiert
das recht auf assistierten suizid gibt
dann ist auch klar dass nicht mehr das
schicksal dafür verantwortlich ist wenn
ich aus krankheit oder pflegebedürftiger
mensch die gesellschaft insbesondere
auch meine verwandten belaste sondern
ich selber bin es der sie belastet und
denn wenn assistierter suizid einmal
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert wird
dann trage ich schließlich die
verantwortung dafür dass ich weiterleben
und die ressourcen der allgemeinheit in
anspruch nehmen will und was
wahrscheinlich viel entscheidender ist
meinen angehörigen zur last fallen
selbst wenn das objektiv nicht stimmt
reicht allein schon das empfinden
anderen zur last zu fallen sich
moralisch verpflichtet zu fühlen sich
für den suizid zu entscheiden und das
ist meine damen und herren ist keine
spekulation sondern die erfahrung aus
ländern in denen schon länger die der
ärztlich assistierter suizid legal
praktiziert wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht wenn man sich
mal das urteil selbst durchliest sagt
selber dass in oregon wo wir eine solche
regelung schon seit über 20 jahren haben
54 prozent derer die sich mit dem
ärztlichen assistenz das leben genommen
haben angegeben haben dass sie sorge
haben ihrer familie freunden pflegenden
zu last zu fallen so das so sagt es
zumindest der offizielle jahresbericht
in oregon von 20 21 und das war dem
bundesverfassungsgericht bekannt und es
trifft eben die sozial schwachen
in oregon warnt 80 der assistierten
suiziden menschen die sich haben
die sich getötet haben
waren menschen die nur die mindest
krankenversorgung bekam die medicaid und
medicare
2008 eingeführt wurde waren es unter
zehn prozent das zeigt auch meine damen
und herren den trend und während
während wir diese diskussion führen
müssen wir einfach auch wissen dass
dieser gesellschaftliche druck natürlich
auch auf andere möglicherweise
übergreift wir haben die diskussion gab
über demenzielle menschen was ist ein
ich mit menschen mit behinderung die
seit ihrer geburt nie als
entwicklungsfähig haben die auch ein
recht auf selbsttötung wie wird das
umgesetzt und wie sieht es denn wirklich
aus werden wir diese hauchdünne
unterscheidung wirklich beibehalten
können zwischen töten auf verlangen
und
der beihilfe zur selbsttötung wie will
ich eigentlich jemand erklären meine
damen und herren
dass er wirklich jemand mehr erklären
dass er zwar das recht auf eine
selbsttötung hat aber wenn er nicht in
der lage ist das glas zu nehmen ihm kein
anderer dieses glas nehmen kann und
deswegen zum schluss meine damen und
herren hoffe ich wenigstens dass wir zu
einer regelung kommt die die
suizidprävention stärkt und die die
schwachen vor vermeintlichen druck
vielen dank
hubert hüppe hat hier auch nochmal seine
bedenken formuliert unter anderem auch
was eine solche regelung für menschen
mit behinderungen bedeuten würde er
engagiert sich schon seit langem in der
behindertenpolitischen arbeit
nochmal einmal daran erinnern fast am
ende dieser debatte dass wir uns glaube
ich darüber einig sind dass jeder der
entwürfe die wir heute diskutieren
besser ist als der aktuelle
rechtszustand der nämlich sehr
ungeregelt ist was viele einzelfragen
angeht und ich glaube wir sind uns auch
einig darüber an dieser debatte dass am
ende dieses gesetzgeberischen prozesses
das klare votum dieses hause steht ja
die autonome
selbsttötung mit assistenz ist zulässig
und sie ist dein recht aber wir müssen
genauso klar die botschaft dagegen
stellen und mit
darzustellen kein leben ist eine last in
dieser gesellschaft menschliches leben
ist immer ein wert an sich und das
ändert sich nicht durch alter und
gebrechlichkeit das ändert sich nicht
durch behinderung das ändert sich nicht
durch eine suchtproblematik oder die
vielen anderen dinge die jeden für sich
selbst in zweifel bringen können ob man
eigentlich in einer situation ist aus
der man doch wieder herausfindet oder ob
man nicht tatsächlich sich für andere zu
einer schwierigkeit ausweitet und das
ist eine gemeinsame aufgabe die wir in
diesem gesetzentwurf nicht werden lösen
können nämlich diesen staat so weiter
auszubauen dass wir stärker zu einer
integrativen inklusiven gesellschaft
kommen die menschen in solchen
situationen abholt und die ihnen klar
signalisiert du bist uns wertvoll denn
jedes menschliche leben ist wertvoll und
es ist keiner wertung durch andere
zugänglich niemals in diesem land wieder
und an dieser stelle ist die
zivilisatorische decke manchmal dünn die
diskussion und pränataldiagnostik um
viele andere dinge haben uns das immer
wieder gezeigt und deswegen ist es
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe zu ermöglichen
was das verfassungsgericht uns
aufgegeben hat aber auch zusagen
menschliches leben ist in deutschland im
jahr 2022 immer wertvoll und wir werden
alles tun sich dabei zu unterstützen es
zu erhalten das ist unsere aufgabe dabei
haben wir eine gemeinsame ich hoffe
daran arbeiten wir auch zusammen vielen
dank
ich trete nicht die kollegin kerstin
griese spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen kollegen ran kann ich sehr
gut anknüpfen denn auch ich sage als
erstes in dieser debatte steht im
mittelpunkt der mensch jeder mensch die
würde jedes menschen und die würde jedes
menschen ist gleich viel wert unabhängig
davon ob er alt krank leiden behindert
ist und der respekt vor der würde des
menschen vor der würde des lebens leitet
mich in dieser debatte
dabei geht es um zwei dinge erstens um
die selbstbestimmung und den freien
willen und es geht und das gehört
zusammen um ein schutzkonzept dass diese
selbstbestimmung gesichert gerade der
schutz von braven gruppen von menschen
die in notsituationen sind in leidenden
situation ist gerade dieser schutz ist
wichtig jedes leben hat die gleiche
würde und niemand hat darüber zu
urteilen ob eines weniger oder mehr
lebenswert wäre
und deshalb unterstütze ich den
gesetzentwurf von lars castellucci und
anderen denn wir wollen wie das
bundesverfassungsgericht es vorgibt
assistierten suizid nach engen regeln
ermöglichen aber wir wollen ihn doch
nicht fördern wir wollen ihnen doch
nicht bewerben wir finden ihn doch nicht
gut sondern wir wollen doch dann wenn
menschen das wollen nach bestimmten
regeln nach zweimaligen arzt gesprächen
nach zeit dazwischen zum nachdenken
ermöglichen aber ihnen doch nicht
fördern sondern wir wollen menschen
unterstützen wenn sie leben wollen
und ich war selbst
bundesverfassungsgerichts bei dem urteil
dabei und das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat selbstverständlich klar ob das
mittel des strafrechts dafür für möglich
gehalten dass hat es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass cannes gegeben so
und deshalb ja wir wollen mit diesem
gesetz sterbehilfe vereine regulieren
wir wollen nicht das was jetzt ist dass
sie unbegrenzt machen können was sie
wollen sondern wir wollen regeln
schaffen nach denen der assistierte
suizid möglicher
und selbstbestimmung kommt nicht unter
den schutz der schwachen funktionieren
die achtung vor dem leben gebietet dass
und ich will dass menschen im pflegeheim
und jeder der das mal erlebt hat weiß
wie das ist ich will dass menschen nicht
unter dem druck druck geraten ihr leben
zu beenden weil dieser druck da ist weil
er assistierte suizid doch ein so
vermeintlich einfache gute schmerzfreie
schnelle lösung wäre ich will dass sie
in diesen situationen allen schutz und
alle hilfe bekommen und
selbstverständlich ist sterbehilfe in
deutschland möglich dass er bis in der
tat der titel der debatte falsch es geht
hier um den assistierten suizid sterben
hilfe beim sterben ist in deutschland
möglich von der palliativen sedierung
über verschiedene formen von abbruch von
behandlungen alles was in
patientenverfügungen steht ist natürlich
möglich damit menschen frei und
selbstbestimmt zu leben und sterben
können wie sie wollen hilfe beim sterben
ist möglich aber es geht eben darum wie
wir die hilfe zum sterben so begrenzt
wie möglich regeln
ich befürchte diesem druck wenn der
assistierte suizid ein normalfall wäre
und ich will nicht dass wir bundesweit
suizid beratungsstellen haben die den
assistierten suizid befördern
stattdessen brauchen wir bundesweit
suizidprävention
wir brauchen unterstützung für menschen
und situationen
und kollegin konnte hat es schon gesagt
erwiesenermaßen dazu gibt es wirklich
viel forschungs hat auch herr
castellucci gesagt ist der suizid wunsch
ein volatiler und der satz ich will
nicht mehr leben bedeutet so oft ich
will so nicht leben und gerade dann kann
man so viel hilfe anbieten und ich danke
allen die sich im hospiz vereinen
engagieren in der palliativmedizin
engagieren davon brauchen wir noch viel
mehr um hilfe begleitung unterstützung
niemand muss qualvoll sterben und vor
allem sollen niemand alleine sterben
müssen
und ich will auch deutlich sagen gar
keine regelung ist keine lösung gar
keine regelung würde
würde wenn sterbehilfe vereinen wie dem
von herrn kusch jetzt für und tor weiter
öffnen das haben wir jetzt diese
situation das halte ich für ethisch
nicht tragbar ich finde wir müssen uns
dieser schwierigen aufgabe stellen als
gesetzgeber dafür regeln zu finden und
auch ein gesellschaftliches klima zu
schaffen dass die würde des menschen in
den mittelpunkt stellt dass die
unterstützung für menschen gerade in
notsituationen in den mittelpunkt stellt
und deshalb haben wir ein gesetzentwurf
entwickelt der den assistierten suizid
nach vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes zwar möglich
macht der dafür aber eben ärztliche
beratung vorsieht einen zeitlichen
abstand und wir haben es verbunden mit
einem antrag der die suizidprävention in
deutschland verbessert wir haben
außerdem ausdrücklich gesagt für unter
18 jährige geht es nicht wir reden ja
darüber wie wir leben wie wir sterben
und das hat viel damit zu tun welches
bild von der gesellschaft haben und
gerade da zeigt dass sich wie wir die
würde jedes einzelnen wahrnehmen ich
freue mich auf gute beratung und hoffe
auf ein gutes gemeinschaftliches
ergebnis
der assistierte suizid darf nicht zum
normalfall werden diese befürchtung
wurde hier schon häufiger in dieser
orientierungs debatte genannt so auch
von kerstin krise die hier auch nochmal
davor gewarnt hat erich irlstorfer
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktion
auch er sitzt sonst im
gesundheitsausschuss
werte herr präsident geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen
der tod gehört zum leben
und jedes leben hat einen wert
doch der
frieden wohlstand und luxus
haben wir dieses ungeliebte thema
sterben und tod
aus der gesellschaftlichen mitte an den
rand unseres denkens und handelns
irgendwie verband
es ist eher die ausnahme dass die
letzten stunden und minuten
und der gewohnten häuslichkeit
erlebt werden dürfen weil wir gott sei
dank sagt
senioreneinrichtungen haben
krankenhäuser und eine äusserst fähige
hospiz infrastruktur
und das hilft uns als angehörige
und es hilft uns dabei die schwersten
stunden
durchzustehen und deshalb an dieser
stelle heute auch mein herzliches
vergelt's gott an alle die hier in den
dienst am menschen leisten
diese orientierungs debatte
ist wichtig und es gibt hat die gruppe
um kollegen prosinger
sie arbeitet hat dass man mit
fachpersonal aus psychiatrie
menschen die den wunsch des sterbens in
sich tragen über alternativen
informieren soll
und sie sagt aber auch dass assistierter
suizid voll ermöglicht werden darf aber
nicht gefördert werden 90 prozent der
fälle entstehen durch und in
ausnahmesituationen
auch das müssen wir uns vor augen halten
das thema missbrauch
soll natürlich geahndet und bestraft
werden das ist klar darüber sind wir uns
eigentlich dass kinder und jugendliche
sind von der sterbehilfe hier
ausgeschlossen
und ich lege einen besonderen wert
darauf dass wir hier gemeinsam darauf
bauen sollen dass die palliativmedizin
und die hospizbewegung nicht nur
grandios leistet sondern dass sie hier
auch ein schlüssel zum besseren lebens
sein kommen und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir die hand reichen zu hilfe und
in meinen augen nicht
natürlich muss kein mensch schmerzen
ertragen es sind medizinisch so weit und
können wirklich auch helfen was sollen
wir tun
und dieses private erlebnis beim sterben
meinen vater das war wirklich eine
erleben was mich sehr geprägt hat wie er
sagte wer ordentlich gelebt hat darf
auch ordentlich sterben
ich habe diese interpretieren wir sind
der wunsch war geheim zu sterben um
seine moment und ich glaube auch dass es
die chance ist nach die kernaufgabe ist
von familie aber auch von kirchen und
glaubensgemeinschaften
hier das thema seelsorge auch in den
mittelpunkt zu stehen und
mich leitet immer noch
dieser satz den herren an höfner von
sich gegeben hat das sagte der mensch
stirbt nicht an einer krankheit sondern
dann wenn gott ein leben vollendet hat
herzlichen dank
erich irlstorfer war das hier mit sehr
persönlichen
beweggründen wie er auf die debatte
schaut und damit kommen wir zum letzten
redner in dieser orientierungs debatte
das ist herbert wollmann spd fraktion
und auch
als letzter redner ist es natürlich
nicht so leicht oder als setzt arena
hier noch neuigkeiten
zu verbreiten aber ich versuche es am
ende meiner rede dann doch wir wissen
dass 2020 im februar das
bundesverfassungsgericht den
strafrechtsparagrafen 217 für nichtig
erklärt hat und das mit einer
gesetzesvorlage von oder begründung von
115 seiten
das gericht hat eindeutig klargemacht
dass die autonomie des einzelnen
menschen in befähigt über sein leben und
seinen tod selbst zu bestimmen dh die
freiheit sich das leben zu nehmen
umfasst auch die freiheit die hilfe
dritter in anspruch zu nehmen rein
formal ist die suizidabsicht nicht nur
zu dulden sondern auch humane weise
sogar zu ermöglichen die sozis absicht
ist darüber hinaus dauert dieses
gesetzes
wieder zu begründen noch zu
rechtfertigen
dabei sind weder alter noch
krankheit einer voraussetzung für die
anspruch nahm suizidhilfe ich betone
umgekehrt das natürlich niemand
verpflichtet werden kann suizidhilfe zu
leisten
warum kommen wir überhaupt zusammen wenn
die fakten so eindeutig sind
ist der so zitierte damit jede
beschränkung genommen worden
da muss ich frau gunners widersprechen
nein wir müssen zusammenkommen das
gericht hat den gesetzgeber ausdrücklich
zu einer detaillierten regulierung der
suizidhilfe beauftragt dabei haben
höchste priorität der nachweis der
freiverantwortlich
die wohl erwogen haid und die
nachhaltigkeit des entschlusses der
suizidwilligen
außerdem das wurde auch schon mehrmals
betont darf der suizid und nicht auf
druck von außen kommen daher kommt der
suizidprävention natürlich mehr denn je
eine enorme bedeutung zu
sozialen notsituation akute
belastungsstörung behandelbare
krankheiten insbesondere aus dem bereich
der psychiatrie müssen sich ja
ausgeschlossen sein bzw behandelt werden
um einen suizid zu verhindern
allein diese beispiele zeigen dass es
einen hohen rahmen personenkreis gibt
der vor dem entschluss sich das leben zu
nehmen unbedingt geschützt werden muss
wer meine rede verfolgt hat hier wird
aufgefallen sein dass sich das wort
sterbehilfe bis jetzt nicht in den mund
genommen habe der titel und das wurde
auch schon gesagt orientierungs debatte
zur sterbehilfe ist im grunde völlig
falsch wir reden hier
wir reden hier über suizidhilfe
suizidhilfe und sterbehilfe sind
verschiedene themenkreise so ehrenwert
wie der hundertste geburtstag ist ich
bewundere das aber das ist nicht der
kern dessen was wir heute oder demnächst
gesprächen und beschließen müssen das
muss ich ganz klar so sagen seit jeher
leisten fachkräfte die sich mit der
medizin am lebensende beruflich
beschäftigen sterbehilfe
auch mir wo sich allerdings ehrlich
sagen würden die fundamentalen
unterschiede zur sterbehilfe und
suizidbeihilfe erst im laufe der zeit
klar und damit wurde mir bewusst dass es
eine sehr sind ihren regelwerkes bedarf
um missbrauch zu verhindern
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch zwei
ganz wesentliche aspekte eingehen
mir ist überhaupt nicht klar wie die
suizidhilfe bei nicht volljährigen zu
regeln ist ich kenne auch keine
positionspapiere die für eine
gesetzesvorlage tauglich wären um kinder
und jugendliche ausreichend zu würdigen
ich möchte auch hinweise es gab vor
kurzem mit dem deutschen ethikrat dazu
eine ein online format und gras ist
dieses thema wurde sehr ausführlich
diskutiert das ist nicht abschließend zu
beurteilen
wir können uns diesen hoch ansiedeln
problem nicht verschließen denn laut
verfassungsgericht und das muss ich
betonen laufe verfassungsrecht gilt das
urteil in jeder phase der menschlichen
existenz ich wiederhole in jeder phase
der menschlichen existenz was immer auch
das zu bedeuten hat die stellungnahme
des deutschen ethikrates ist erst im
september zu erwarten das haben sie uns
vorher mittwoch mitgeteilt
das heißt wir sollten nicht vorschnell
jetzt dinge versuchen umzusetzen die in
der vorigen legislaturperiode
versäumt worden danke
vielen dank herr kollege weil man damit
schließlich die aussprache und gibt es
soweit war also hier diese orientierungs
debatte in der die abgeordneten
unabhängig von ihrer parteizugehörigkeit
ihre meinung ihre position zu diesem
doch sehr schwierigen thema äußern
konnten das war hat man auch gemerkt es
war eine nicht polemisch geführte
nachdenkliche debatte hier denn die
abwägung zwischen dem schutz des lebens
und das selbstbestimmungsrecht das ist
nicht leicht wie man das in ein gesetz
fassen kann es gibt bisher drei
gesetzentwürfe die jetzt noch weiter
ausgearbeitet werden können eventuell
kommen auch noch neue gesetzentwürfe
dazu im sommer soll es eine erste lesung
dann hier im parlament zu
gesetzentwürfen geben und im herbst so
ist momentan der plan soll dann
abschließend darüber abgestimmt werden
in der letzten legislaturperiode hat das
nicht geklappt eine einigung zu finden
nun geht es in dieser legislatur
natürlich noch etwas mehr zeit der
bundestag befasst sich jetzt noch mit
weiteren themen wie es weitergeht das
sagt ihn gleich meine kollegin jeanette
klag
[Applaus]
so wehrte zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
wir machen einen harten themen schnitt
der bundestag hat noch weitere themen an
diesem sitzungstag an diesem mittwoch
auf seiner tagesordnung stehen es geht
jetzt um ein zukunftszentrum dass die
bundesregierung errichten möchte die
idee geht auf die empfehlung der
kommission 30 jahre friedliche
revolution und deutsche einheit zurück
die in der letzten legislatur getagt hat
und mit dieser neuen institution will
die bundesregierung vor allem die
erfahrung der ostdeutschen mit wandel
und umbrüchen würdigen behörden in die
debatte ein und
weiteres erfüllen wir dann bei den
nächsten redner erster jetzt am
rednerpult ist bernhard hermann für
bündnis 90 die grünen
mutige frauen und männer in der ddr
friedlich gegen die sed-diktatur
aufgelehnt haben
wir haben uns getraut und haben
widerstand in einer diktatur geleistet
unser wunsch nach freiheit demokratie
und selbstbestimmung war ungebrochen
als die im jahr 2020 unser jubiläum
feierten blendeten wir viel aus zb den
bereits seit jahren andauernden krieg in
der ost ukraine
wir ahnten nicht welche konsequenzen das
haben würde auch für uns
werden sich viele menschen im westlichen
teil unseres landes infolge der
wiedervereinigung kaum etwas verändern
mussten außer überspitzt gesagt ein paar
zahlen auf dem lohnzettel durch den soli
den ja alle zeiten wurden im anderen
teil unseres landes ganze leben auf den
kopf gestellt
während die einen wie gewohnt in ihrem
sommerurlaub fuhren
wurden die anderen über nacht arbeitslos
während die einen in ihrem gewohnten
umfeld wohnen blieben als wäre nichts
gewesen mussten die anderen ihre
familien verlassen und arbeitet in
anderen teilen der republik suchen
von einem tag auf den anderen mussten
ostdeutsche sich aber in einem völlig
fremden system zurechtfinden
sicherlich all das geschah aufgrund des
wunsches nach freiheit und
selbstbestimmung
doch solche um brüche gehen auch an
einem nach freiheit strebenden menschen
nicht spurlos vorbei
mit diesen schilderungen geht es mir
nicht ausdrücklich nicht darum wunde und
gräben zwischen ost und west aufzureißen
sondern gegenseitiges verständnis zu
schaffen
auch wenn die transformation seit der
wiedervereinigung eine gesamtdeutsche
aufgabe ist die starken politischen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
einschnitte trugen die menschen in
ostdeutschland
den westdeutschen blieben sie
überwiegend unbekannt
und wenn wir also von transformation
sprechen sollten wir immer beachten dass
dahinter ganz konkrete biografien ganz
reale menschen mit beachtlichen
lebensleistungen stehen das
zukunftszentrum
kann mit einer wissenschaftlichen und
kulturellen aufarbeitung im dialog dies
aufzeigen und den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt stärken
während wir in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten den blick stark nach innen
richten
und eine er in der deutsche betrachtung
des transformationsprozesses einnahmen
klammerten vieler die historische
europäische perspektive aus dabei wird
gab es bereits in den 70er und 80er
jahren in polen in ungarn der cssr und
auch der ddr zivilgesellschaftliche
bestrebungen nach demokratischer
selbstbestimmung und der wahrung der
menschenrechte
doch nicht nur das wissen hierzulande
viele nicht
möglicherweise waren fehlendes wissen
oder die fehlende sensibilität die
gründe auch dafür dass die mir dann
proteste in der ukraine ende 2013 anfang
2014 bei vielen schnell in vergessenheit
gerieten
unserer erinnerungskultur bot für die
demokratischen bestrebungen in ost und
mitteleuropa
weder vor dem zerfall der sowjetunion
nacht danach jenseits von sonntagsreden
viel platz und das trotz durchaus
ähnliche erfahrungen zumindest der
ostdeutschen
die frage nach dem warum müssen wir uns
alle stellen
und so machen uns die ereignisse in der
ukraine und der seit dem 24 februar
andauernde angriffskrieg russlands den
blick nicht nur auf uns selbst zu
richten vielmehr sollten wir den
betrachtung stars auf die transformation
in europa erweitern
so kann ich persönlich den
unterzeichnern des offenen briefes mit
über 95 wissenschaftlerinnen an der
stelle gut verstehen denn um die
transformation der neunziger jahre zu
verstehen und einzuordnen muss deren
vorgeschichte seit den 1970 er jahren
ebenso einbezogen werden
wie ihr gesamteuropäische rahmen
das zukunftszentrum sollte als
brückenbauer zwischen ost und west
europa fungieren um die geschichte der
postkommunistischen
regionen nicht nur in deutschland
sondern in westeuropa bekannter zu
machen und den einsatz der
zivilgesellschaft für demokratie in
diesen ländern zu würdigen denn eine
nationale betrachtung der geschichte
greift zu kurz und nur wenn wir
gegenseitiges verständnis auch an dieser
stelle aufbringen kann europa
zusammenwachsen
nach mehr als drei jahrzehnten im
vereinigten deutschland ist es wichtig
dass unser land weiterhin
mit unseren nachbarn eng
zusammenarbeitet wir gemeinsam die
demokratie in deutschland und auch in
ganz europa stärken nun geht es darum
den standort in den ländern brandenburg
sachsen mecklenburg-vorpommern
sachsen-anhalt oder thüringen in einem
standortwettbewerb auszuloten und die
gestaltung des zentrums zügig und
transparent mit einem gesamteuropäischen
blick auf die geschichte deutschlands
und ost und mitteleuropas voranzubringen
eine breite gesellschaftliche debatte
zur stärkung des profils des zukunfts
zentrums wäre sehr wünschenswert
ich bin davon überzeugt dass das
zukunftszentrum als begegnungsort einen
wichtigen beitrag zum diskurs zwischen
wissenschaft kultur und
zivilgesellschaft leisten wird und so
für die folgen der transformation
erfahrungen deutschlands und seiner
nachbarn gegenseitiges verständnis
schaffen und den europäischen
zusammenhalt fördern wird vielen dank
bernard herrmann für die grünen hat hier
die debatte eröffnet also ein
zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit
europäische transformation das haben die
ampel parteien bereits in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag
aufgenommen die initiative von dieser
kommission die in der letzten legislatur
gearbeitet hat jetzt geht es auch noch
darum wo soll das zukunftszentrum stehen
yvonne mack war es jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
den vierzigsten jahrestag der
staatsgründung
an diesem tag gingen in plauen in meiner
heimat rund 15.000 mutige menschen auf
die straße und sie protestierten
gemeinsam gegen die zustände im land
jörg schneider ein ehemaliger
wehrpflichtiger bei den grenztruppen hat
zuvor heimlich flugblätter verteilt und
zu dieser demonstration aufgerufen
wie von geisterhand setzte sich damals
ohne erkennbare führung der
demonstrationszug in bewegung
erste sprechchöre wurden laut die ersten
transparente für reformen reisefreiheit
und frieden erschienen die staatsmacht
setzte wasserwerfer ein doch ist lang
doch es gelang nicht die menge
aufzulösen
das war der beginn der großdemonstration
in der ddr der wille zur veränderung und
das verlangen nach freiheit waren
stärker als die angst vorm
sicherheitsapparat vor maschinenpistolen
und wasserwerfern in blauen nahmen die
unmittelbare friedliche revolution ihren
anfang
ohne diese friedliche revolution hätte
es die deutsche einheit nicht gegeben
die wiedervereinigung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ist das große deutsche
glücks ereignis unserer jüngeren
geschichte
aus wir sind das volk wurde auch damals
schnell wir sind ein volk und es folgten
beispielslose transformations-
entwicklungen in den neuen bundesländern
ebenso wie in allen ländern mittel und
osteuropas
schmerzhaft waren sie gleichwohl sie
haben narben hinterlassen
aber wenn man heute durch unsere städte
und gemeinden geht sieht man auch was
alles entstanden und gelungen ist
und auch die europäische einheit meine
damen und herren ist damit fest
verbunden ein weiterer großer glücksfall
auch und gerade für uns deutsche
meine fraktion
unterstützt die gute idee eines zentrums
für europäische transformation und
deutsche einheit
diese wurde von der kommission 30 jahre
friedliche revolution der letzten
bundesregierung erarbeitet wir danken
allen mitgliedern für die arbeit und wir
begrüßen auch das erarbeitete konzept
welches auf drei säulen fußt
wissenschaft kultur sowie dialog und
begegnung
die staatlichen wirtschaftlichen und die
gesellschaftliche veränderungen seit
1989 und 1990 und ihre auswirkungen auf
die menschen sind bisher sehr wenig
systematisch erforscht und aus diesen
erfahrungen und mit dem europäische
blick können wir für die kommenden
transformationen auch wertvolle schlüsse
ziehen wir sollten heute schon
definieren wie wir diese
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse für
nachfolgende generationen nutzbar machen
wie finden sie ihren weg in die
schulbücher zum beispiel
für ebenso wichtig halte ich das
geplante vorhaben neue formate des
gesprächs zwischen bürgerschaft
fachleuten und entscheidungsträgerinnen
und entscheidungsträger zu finden wir
müssen reden trifft ist ziemlich gut
es besteht immer deutscher und
grenzüberschreitende gesprächsbedarf
immer noch und immer wieder und dem
sollten wir raum geben
jetzt gibt es eine vielzahl von guten
ideen bewerbungen und vor allem gibt es
eine breite debatte die sehen hier aber
noch am beginn wir plädieren also dafür
jetzt auch nicht zu überstürzen uns eher
ein paar monate mehr zeit zu nehmen und
die fenster und türen der diskussion
weit offen zu halten
natürlich dann mit einem ergebnis mit
einem ergebnis zum standort und vor
allem aber zum konzept
der deutsche bundestag wir als
abgeordnete
sollten dabei ein sehr zentraler akteur
sein
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen uns unbedingt mit einem impuls
zivilgesellschaft getragen unter anderem
auch von fünf ehemaligen
kommissionsmitgliedern befassen sie
fordern ich zitiere eine
weiterentwicklung zu einem europäischen
freiheits und zukunftszentrum dass die
politischen und kulturellen bedürfnisse
bündnisse zwischen der deutschen
zivilgesellschaft und den europäischen
nachbarn stärkt um gemeinsam freiheit
und demokratie gegen autoritäre
herrschaft zu verteidigen
im angesichts der aggressiv
imperialistischen politik des
autokratisch putin russlands spricht da
vieles dafür dies einzubinden und wir
haben auch schon vorbilder
und es gibt auch schon vorbilder in den
euro regionen beispielsweise in der
euro-region grenze da haben bayern und
sachsen und thüringen und tschechien
gemein gemeinsam schon viel erfahrung
mit großen wie kleinen
grenzüberschreitenden projekten und an
dieser nahtstelle zwischen
mittelosteuropa ost und westdeutschland
werden
transformationsprozesse gemeinsam erlebt
und bewältigt und diese gilt es
wissenschaftlich mehr zu nutzen zum
schluss lieber herr präsident
auch die weiteren guten empfehlungen der
regierungskommission sollten umgesetzt
werden beispielsweise das angedachte
ostdeutsche
begabtenförderungswerk nun liebe
bundesregierung lieber carsten schneider
seid ihr gefragt und gefordert vielen
dank
sagte yvonne hak was hier für die
unionsfraktion ja zukunftszentrum soll
in ostdeutschland stehen soll noch eine
standortentscheidung geben und
beispielsweise aus sachsen aus dem
bundesland aus dem yvonne mag was kommt
hat sich blauen zusammen mit leipzig
beworben jetzt der ostbeauftragte der
bundesregierung carsten schneider
staatsminister im kanzleramt hat vor 14
tagen die eckpunkte vorgelegt
kollegen meine damen und herren in
bildschirm liebe kollegin mag was vielen
dank für ihre rede auch kolleginnen und
kollegen die noch folgen gesprochen
haben auch für die unterstützung für
dieses zentrum dieses zentrum für
deutsche einheit und europäische
transformation es ist wie bereits
ausgeführt wurde ein auftrag aus der
regierung der einheits kommission 30
jahre deutsche einheit die wir vor zwei
jahren hat die leider insbesondere weist
die begegnung betrifft zwischen ost und
west zwischen nord und süd aber auch
groß und kleinstädten oder auch leuten
die vor 1990 geboren worden leuten die
nach 1990 geboren wurden diese begegnung
haben maximal an der bildschirm kassel
stattfinden können das ist bedauerlich
weil es zeit gewissen wäre auch nach
diesen aufregenden spannen umwelt in den
30 jahren mal kurz innezuhalten sie
fragen was es mit unserer gesellschaft
gemacht hat und ob wir eng beieinander
sind oder ob wir uns vielleicht mental
auseinander bewegen bewegt haben oder ob
wir zwischen land stadt und land die
unterschiede größer sind als sie
zwischen ost und west sind als spannende
fragen die in diesen zukunftsbezogenen
werden sollen wie auch die frage der
transformation das klingt ja so
technisch also die komplette umwälzung
einer gesellschaft von der totalen
sicherheit im sinne von den arbeitsplatz
sicher dann dein leben wird gesteuert zu
du kannst alles selbst in die hand
nehmen und bist frei
diese freiheit von oder freiheit für für
viele in erfüllung gegangen ich verwende
14 mal kann ich da sagen für meine
familie ich kenne aber auch andere bei
denen das nicht der fall war und was wir
lesen zentrum machen wollen ist für
einen bieter interesse füreinander auch
zu wecken also für die unterschiedlichen
begegnung zwischen ost und west und kann
nur sagen dass ich meiner zeit in erfurt
wir hatten den ersten austausch mit
anderen katholischen mädchengymnasium
limburg innere mich da noch sehr
gespannt daran als wir dann da heißt
14-jährige plattenbau kinder darauf
schlugen das war dass das war ein
kulturschock
da stattgefunden hat aber es war ein
spannender und interessanter soviel kann
ich verraten und meine kollegen meine
freunde von damals wissen noch genau was
ich meine dies hat allerdings weniger in
den letzten jahren stattgefunden um
ehrlich zu sein und ich finde dass dies
nicht nur notwendig ist sondern dass es
eine gesellschaft auch ausmacht zu
reflektieren und eben auch neugierig zu
bleiben
wir starten diese standortwettbewerb so
wie sie ihn uns beauftragt haben vielen
dank für diese unterstützung
für staaten in ergebnisoffen und auch ob
das ganz klar zu sagen die kriterien die
wir anlegen sind die die die eines
kommissionen auch die letzte
bundesregierung in ihrem beschluss im
juni gefasst hat und die sich auch in
ihrem antrag des bundestages
wiederfinden und ich möchte sie auch
herzlich einladen dass auch wir die
diese entscheidung in einer durch auch
eine konsultation mit den fraktionen in
einer jury treffen in der ich zum
beispiel dass mich auch klar sagen gar
kein stimmrecht haben möchte weil ich
nicht möchte dass das so aussieht als
sei taste vorgeben sondern ist offen und
ich bin wirklich sehr begeistert wie
viele städte in ostdeutschland ich hatte
gelegenheit im blauen frau kollegin
machst mir das anzugucken auch jena ich
meine anlagen von frankfurt oder ich
komme demnach
die dann auch die kommission das aber
das interesse da ist das ist diesen
bundespolitische leuchtturm geben soll
zweiter punkt den ich hier aber noch
ansprechen will ist nicht nur dass wir
eine nabelschau ost und west machen
sondern dass wir den europäischen blick
mit in den
repliken im blick nämlich super deutsche
ausdruck den ich ja gerade verliert
haben also das wird jeden den
europäischen blick weiten und deswegen
habe ich meine erste reise in meiner
funktion als dienstreisen ins ausland
auch nachtrag gemacht ganz bewusst und
ich kann nicht sagen dass die
tschechische regierung auch klar gesagt
hat sie wollen sich an diesem projekt
beteiligen sich mit einbringen und ich
werde juni nach
mit ihrer unterstützung auch nach polen
reisen um auch dort dafür zu werben dass
wir die mittel osteuropäischen länder
als bestandteil der neuen europäischen
union aber eben auch als frühere
bestandteil der anderen seite des
eisernen vorhangs
für ostdeutsche sehr froh und dankbar
sind das ist in polen mit der
solidarnosc bewegung auch in ungarn aber
auch in prag mit der botschaft dass es
dort die bewegung hin zur freiheit gab
die uns die möglichkeit gegeben hat die
mauer auch ein zu stützen
und zu oft habe ich das will ich
selbstkritisch sagen den blick nach
westen gerichtet das meint gar nicht
komplett sondern paris london washington
als politische aktion und zu wenig und
zu selten nach venus
bukarester oder prag und ich finde dass
uns das gut ansteht als bundesrepublik
deutschland und ich lade sie hat sich
dazu einen fingern
lassen schneider war das der
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung er
hat eckpunkte vorgelegt für die
errichtung eines zukunftszentrum für die
deutsche einheit und europäische
transformation und parallel dazu gibt es
von den koalitionsfraktionen einen
entsprechenden antrag das ist beides die
grundlage der heutigen debatte
meine damen und herren um es vorweg zu
nehmen unser problem mit dem zukunfts
zentrum für europäische transformation
und deutsche einheit ist nicht dass die
lebensleistung der ostdeutschen
gewürdigt und wissenschaftlich erforscht
werden soll dass ausstellungen und
bürgerdialoge dazu stattfinden wir sind
die letzten die das nicht unterstützen
würden unser problem ist dass dieser
aspekt immer weiter in den hintergrund
tritt zugunsten der sogenannten
europäischen transformation auf den
letzten metern haben sie auch den titel
geändert die deutsche einheit steht
jetzt nur noch an zweiter stelle und das
lässt tief blicken sie versuchen hier
das historische narrativ zu etablieren
die friedliche revolution und die
deutsche einheit seien quasi nichts
anderes gewesen als eine art
durchgangsstadium zu einem bunten und
vielfältigen
europa aber die bürger der ehemaligen
ddr meine damen und herren sind 89 auf
die straße gegangen unter einsatz ihres
lebens für ihre freiheit in einem
geeinten und souveränen deutschland und
nicht dafür dass unsere souveränität an
einen europäischen superstaat mit sitz
in brüssel verscherbelt wird
ihr antrag spricht ja nur sehr abstrakt
und verwaschen von transformation der
klartext findet sich in den vorschlägen
der so genannten konferenz zur zukunft
europas die das eu parlament in seiner
letzten sitzungswoche quasi unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
verabschiedet hat was kommt da alles auf
uns zu eine gemeinsame europäische armee
vereinheitlichte steuerpolitik
verschärfte sanktionsmöglichkeiten gegen
einzelne mitgliedstaaten aufgabe des
einstimmigkeitsprinzips sowie
gesamteuropäische volksabstimmungen mit
anderen worten die südstaaten südländer
werden demnächst mit ihrer mehrheit über
die zahlungsverpflichtungen deutschlands
entscheiden und ganz wichtig ihr
lieblingsprojekt umsetzung einer
gemeinsamen und kollektiven
migrationspolitik inklusive aufklärung
von kindern ab beginn der grundschule
über migration und integration
meine damen und herren eine
amerikanische bundesstaat wird mehr
nationale souveränität besitzen als
deutschland nach diesen reformen wir
werden zu einer tribut flüchtigen
corinths brüssel star abgestuft und sie
alle die demokratisch sich demokratisch
nennen den parteien haben dem in
straßburg zugestimmt das ist das
gegenteil von demokratisch denn ohne das
deutsche staats volk als souverän hört
die demokratie zu in exten deutschland
zu existieren auf das sollten sie dem
volk zumindest auch offen sagen und vor
diesem hintergrund weist all die
plakative bürgerbeteiligung in der
zukunftskonferenz wir jetzt auch in dem
zukunftszentrum doch einen deutlich
deutlichen ali k darf man kann sich des
eindrucks einer demokratie simulation
nicht erwehren zumal sie ja vor allem
die sogenannte zivilgesellschaft
einbeziehen wollen als regierungs
konforme angels die sich selbst mit
steuermitteln zuvor sich heran gezogen
haben und wenn wir dann noch lesen im
abschlussbericht der kommission 30 jahre
deutsche einheit es gebe ich zitiere
noch immer ein signifikant höheres
niveau an rassismus fremden und
ausländerfeindlichkeit in ostdeutschland
daher solle sich das zu gründende
zukunftszentrum der frage nach den
bedingungen weltoffener und damit
zukunftsfähige verhältnisse in
ostdeutschland mit besonderer
dringlichkeit vor dringlichkeit wittmann
in großen lettern geschrieben
dann wird doch die arrogante attitüde
offenbar wie sie den ostdeutschen in
wahrheit immer noch entgegen bringen
nehmen sie endlich zur kenntnis dass man
in dresden oder rostock keine
verhältnisse wie in frankfurt
bahnhofsviertel oder in duisburg marxloh
haben will das ist absolut legitim und
es ist infam das als rassismus zu
diffamieren
ich komme zum schluss wir stimmen
dennoch nicht gegen ein zukunftszentrum
für deutsche einheit sondern wir werden
uns enthalten fallen wegen der positiven
potenziale wenn sie es ernst machen
wirklich mit der ostmitteleuropäischen
vernetzung und wirklich vertreter der
mehrheitsmeinung aus polen etwa oder aus
ungarn zu wort kommen lassen dann könnte
sogar manche verirrungen in sachen
migration oder europäische
zentralisierungen hierzulande heilsam
korrigiert werden vielen dank
vielen dank
das nächste reden hält das wort kollege
thomas hacker fdp fraktion
thomas hacker für jeden liberalen er
sitzt im ausschuss für kultur und medien
der herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir kommen zurück zum thema die
bilder prägten sich ein
am 27 juni 89 durchschnitten der
aussenminister ungarns bühler horn und
sein österreichischer kollege alois mock
bei sopron den grenzzaun zwischen beiden
ländern der erste zaun zwischen ost und
west öffnete sich die grenzen im herzen
europas folgten die mauer wurde
eingedrückt da ist eine vorhang war
vergangenheit das waren die sichtbaren
zeichen einer bewegung der menschen
ihres kampfes für freiheit und
demokratie die friedliche revolution
erfasste die ddr die samtene die
tschechoslowakei und die singende das
baltikum die in polen losgetreten wellen
setzen sich fort und erfassten die
menschen in der sowjetunion in den
ländern des warschauer pakts bis weiter
an die bulgarische schwarzmeerküste mit
einer unvergleichlichen dynamik die
freiheit hatte gesiegt als sozialistisch
geprägten gesellschaften entstanden
marktwirtschaftlich orientierte
demokratie aus den gelebten utopien des
real existierenden sozialismus wurden
mit einem schlag transformations-
gesellschaften in denen die menschen
ihren platz finden mussten der
systemwechsel darauf die menschen
unvorbereitet und mit allen konsequenzen
für ihr leben ihr berufliches und vor
allem ihr privates leben ja es gab
gesellschaftliche brüche die bis heute
nicht geheilt sind und große
enttäuschungen die bis heute nicht
überwunden sind das lässt sich nicht
beschönigen und auch nicht leugnen und
doch ostdeutsche städte und gemeinden
haben sich zu boom regionen mit hoher
wirtschaftsdynamik hervorragende
lebensqualität einer exzellenten
hochschullandschaft und großer
innovationskraft entwickelt
zukunftsweisende unternehmen
zukunftsweisender nehmen schafft neue
arbeitsplätze gerade auch in letzter
zeit heute ist der lebensstandard der
menschen in ostdeutschland deutlich
gewachsen natürlich gibt es weiter
aufholbedarf so unvorbereitet der
systemwechsel kam die danach gemachten
erfahrungen bei uns und unseren nachbarn
scheint vieles gemeinsam zu haben von
diesen erfahrungen lernen ist der weg
den wir mit dem zug zentrum für
europäische transformation und deutsche
einheit bestreiten wollen mit diesem
zukunftszentrum bekommen eine
einrichtung einen thinktank von
gesamteuropäischer bedeutung eine
bedeutung die das europäische zentrum
der solidarnosc in danzig bereits hat es
erinnert an die geschichte und behauptet
sich auch in zeiten
nationalkonservativen gegenwinds und
ihren gegenwind ertragen wir auch es
arbeitet für unsere gemeinsame
europäische identität ist man dann die
bedeutung von frieden demokratie und
freiheit und daran werden wir auch sie
immer erinnern heute ist das wichtiger
denn je das gemeinsame ist das zentrale
element dass das zukunftszentrum künftig
in den mittelpunkt stellen soll wir
wünschen uns dass die erfahrungen zu
vieler menschen die glücklich nun die
bitteren die lebensleistung in eine
größere würdigung erfahren damit
gesellschaftliche brüche gehalt und
enttäuschungen überwunden werden wir
wollen dass das zukunftszentrum ein ort
wird der breit getragen wird und zeigt
dass die deutsche einheit immer ein teil
einer europäischen einigung war daran
wollen wir arbeiten gemeinsam für die
menschen in deutschland in europa danke
thomas hacker wartest für die fdp und
wir hören jetzt gesine lötzsch für die
linke die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich bin eine
große freundin der wissenschaft doch was
untersucht werden soll in diesem zentrum
das kann in jeder ostdeutsche auf der
straße erzielen wenn sie untersuchen
wollen warum viele menschen in
ostdeutschland die deutsche einheit als
fremdgesteuert wahrnehmen schauen sie
doch einfach mal wer in den chefetagen
in ostdeutschland und in der
bundesregierung sitzt da kann man die
ostdeutschen mit der lupe suchen und das
ist zu viele fremde stimmen oder nicht
der treuhand an das war eine industrie
vernichtungs maschine sie hat den
maximal möglichen schaden verursacht sie
hatten hat ostdeutschland die
industrialisiert und die abwicklung von
die abwicklung von wirtschaft
wissenschaft sport und kultur haben in
ostdeutschland dauerhaften schaden
angerichtet und darüber müssen wir reden
meine damen und herren auf unsere
nachfrage
hat die bundesregierung berichtet dass
von 1998
bis heute 90 prozent aller öffentlichen
bibliotheken und nahezu zwei drittel der
theater in ostdeutschland geschlossen
wurden ebenso verhält es sich mit den
kinos und selbst jedes zweite orchester
im osten ist mittlerweile spurlos
verschwunden und das ist der falsche weg
meine damen und herren
darum muss lust auf die richtige
schlussfolgerung sein wir müssen endlich
wirksame dinge für die menschen in
ostdeutschland tun wir müssen verhindern
dass ein großer teil der ostdeutschen
rentner in altersarmut verfolgt tun sie
etwas damit die menschen ihre miete und
ihre heizkosten bezahlen können und wenn
wir den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
stärken wollen dann reicht ein
zukunftszentrum nicht aus sondern wir
brauchen in jeder stadt ein kulturhaus
und einen öffentlichen sportplatz meine
damen und herren und kommunen fehlen
über
159 milliarden euro an investitionen hat
uns die kfw kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau folge rechnet allein für
schulen fehlen über 45 milliarden euro
also müssen wir hier mehr geld
reinstecken denn in schulen und
universitäten wird gelehrt und geforscht
und dort sollen jugendliche die
demokratie jeden tag erleben können
meine damen und herren und vor allem das
ist die feste überzeugung der linken
sollen die jugendlichen lernen dass
krieg kein mittel der politik mehr sein
darf und dass aufrüstung keinen frieden
sichern meine damen und herren eine
europäische zukunft werden wir haben
wenn wir sie gemeinsam friedlich
gestalten und das ist unser
grundanliegen vielen dank
gesine lötzsch für die linke war das ja
das zentrum soll zumindest nach dem
eckpunktepapier drei aufgaben haben
forschung zu den umbrüchen nach der
vereinigung ausstellungen die auch die
leistungen beispielsweise der
ostdeutschen würdigen sowie ein raum für
begegnungen und veranstaltungen aber
inhaltlich gefüllt werden noch
detaillierter soll das ganze ja auch es
geht natürlich nicht nur um die
standortauswahl um einen wettbewerb der
städte nächste rednerin katrin budde für
die spd
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wenn sie bei facebook werbung bekommen
mit der frage sind sie 1965 geboren oder
früher und dann das angebot für ein
super kleines leistungsfähiges hörgerät
kommt oder wenn sie beim eintrag des
geburtsjahres im formular so lange
zurück scrollen müssen dass es schon
denken kommt das noch dann wissen sie
sie haben schon ein ganz schönes stück
lebenszeit hinter sich gebracht bei mir
ist das jedenfalls sohn und ich sage für
mich es war eine gute lebenszeit bis
hierher eine lebenszeit in zwei staaten
die unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten
ich war teil einer friedlichen
revolution ich habe die spd eine freie
demokratische parteien meiner region mit
gegründet und aufgebaut ich war teil des
aufbaus meinen des bundeslandes ich habe
struktur brüche gesehen und
strukturwandel gestaltet als
landespolitikerin als landesministerin
zum teil erfolgreich aber oft genug bin
ich auch gegen wände gerannt ich habe
als junge diplom ingenieurin erlebt wie
mir schlechter qualifizierte
erwachsenenbildner aus dem westen etwas
beibringen wollten und wie haupt
technologen großer ostdeutscher betriebe
den kopf eingezogen haben weil sie nicht
wussten was im neuen system sagen dürfen
ich habe miterlebt wie meine eltern ende
50 aus dem berufsleben ausscheiden
mussten und ihr leben komplett neu
sortieren mussten und ich habe gejubelt
typen von mckinsey und sed little erlebt
die noch hier einen betrieb von innen
gesehen hatten die uns aber erzählen
wollte mir mal die betriebe
umstrukturiert und ich habe auch
miterlebt wie für gestaltungswillen wie
viel mut und kraft in einer gesellschaft
steckt trotzdem der alltag ihrer
menschen von einem tag auf den anderen
komplett anders war
was aber mein persönliches leben
beschreibt ist dass ich immer teil derer
war die gestaltet haben für viele
menschen in ostdeutschland und osteuropa
war und ist das anders sie waren und
sind teil eines prozesses aber mit weit
weniger aktiven gestaltungs und
entscheidungsmöglichkeiten wir wissen
heute dass die zeit nach 1990 nur sehr
wenig mit strukturwandel dafür aber umso
mehr mit struktur brüchen zu tun hatte
das war in ostdeutschland zu aber wir
wurden durch das vereinte wiedervereinte
deutschland in einem gemeinsamen system
nicht nur sozial aufgefangen sondern für
uns gab es eine besondere bessere
situation und trotzdem behaupte ich dass
auch heute noch in den tiefen der weiter
westlich liegenden deutschen
bundesländer sehr viel nicht klar ist
wie groß der bruch 1990 war das eher
gesellschaftlich viel viel tiefer ging
als vermutet wird und daraus auch ein
teil der deutsch-deutschen
missverständnisse resultieren
das ist weder jammern noch anklagen wer
mich kennt weiß dass ich weder das eine
noch das andere tue und der weg aus der
diktatur aus rein in die demokratische
gesellschaft war und ist für mich
alternativlos aber wenn man selbst nicht
teil einer so tief greifenden
gesellschaftlichen transformation ist
hat man ganz andere alltagssorgen und
die prägen dann eben auch das
verständnis um aber zu verstehen und zu
lernen muss strukturwandel strukturbruch
transformationen mit seinen
gesellschaftlichen auswirkungen stärker
noch in den fokus rücken eine säule des
zukunftszentrum soll diese gigantische
aufgabe übernehmen und diese
transformations- forschung muss im
ständige auseinandersetzung mit der
gesellschaft stattfinden an einem ort wo
veränderung auf veränderung trifft und
wo geballte bevölkerungs meinung auf
wissenschaft trifft meine damen und
herren wie viel härter muss der prozess
und war es auch in den osteuropäischen
nachbarländern gewesen sein die
entwicklung ostdeutschlands muss deshalb
auch immer im kontext mit der
entwicklung in osteuropa gesehen
ivan krastev schreibt immer wieder sehr
deutlich und sehr deutlich darüber warum
regionen oder nationen die gezwungen
werden oder die sich auch selber dazu
entscheiden andere gesellschaftliche
systeme anzunehmen zu imitieren nicht
glücklich werden sein zitat das leben
des imitators wird zunehmend von
gefühlen der unzulänglichkeit
minderwertigkeit abhängigkeit und das
verlust der eigenen identität beherrscht
es lohnt sich übrigens diese aufsätze in
gänze zu lesen denn wenn er auch
eigentlich über die osteuropäischen
staaten schreibt beschreibt er ein
problem das wir alle gemeinsam auch in
deutschland haben in dem prozess den
willy brandt beschrieben hat mit es
wächst zusammen was zusammen gehört aber
es wächst noch den satz wir wollen kein
imitat des westens sein den höre ich und
viele von uns seit über zwei jahrzehnten
auch in ostdeutschland und das müssen
wir ernst nehmen deshalb brauchen wir
den dialog mit einer gesellschaftlicher
dialog zwischen bürgerinnen und bürgern
unterschiedlicher regionen zwischen
generationen die backen ort und
begegnungszentrums das soll die zweite
säule des zukunftszentrum sein wir
brauchen in unserer zeit mit ihren
großen globalen neuen herausforderungen
keine fragmentierung der gesellschaft
sondern wir brauchen zusammenhalt
einander verstehen im besten falle
verständnis füreinander und die aktive
entscheidung dafür die herausforderungen
gemeinsam anzugehen
und was wäre dialog ohne kultur deshalb
steht über der dritten säule des
zukunftszentrum das wort kulturzentrum
wer eine ahnung davon bekommen will von
welcher idee wir uns dabei leiten lassen
haben sollte sich das solidarisch
zentrum in danzig ansehen ständige
ausstellungen und temporäre kulturelle
bildung künstlerische auseinandersetzung
mit phänomenen der gesellschaftlichen
transformationen würdigung
gesellschaftlicher und individueller
lebensleistung austausch über die
geschichtliche entwicklung bis ins heute
und ideenentwicklung für das morgen
wanderausstellungen die republik dass es
nur eine unvollständige und kurze
beschreibung und trotz der
unterschiedlichen entwicklungen im neuen
größeren europa haben wir über die jahre
ein gutes ein neues europa ein stärkeres
europa aufgebaut das sich in krisen
gegenseitig stützt und wir erleben seit
dem überfall russlands auf die ukraine
wie stark dieses neue europa trotz der
unterschiedlichkeiten ist und wir stehen
alle vor großen herausforderungen die
nächsten transformationsprozesse stehen
zinshaus energie ist dabei ein großes
thema die auswirkungen auf die
automobilindustrie betreffen alle
regionen europas mit ihren
arbeitsplätzen
und deshalb lassen sie uns gute ideen
für ein gutes gemeinsames morgen
entwickeln ein dank noch zum schluss an
alle die in der kommission und im
zukunftszentrum mitgearbeitet haben als
teil beider gruppen weiß ich wie
arbeitsaufwendig und intensiv der
prozess war
und eine entschuldigung an die
cdu/csu-fraktion ich würde es ja auch
sagen sie sind als koalitionspartner der
letzten legislatur gleichsam mit geburts
etwa dieses zentrum ist mein versorgen
das ich hab sie einfach zu spät
eingebunden dann hätte es auch ein
gemeinsamer antrag sein können ich würde
mich aber freuen wenn wir den prozess
jetzt weiter gemeinsam alle gehen hier
wenn der im plenum und auch im ausschuss
beraten vielen dank wir bestellen antrag
den katrin budde hier erwähnt das ist
der antrag der ampel fraktionen aber da
die idee dieses zukunft sie zentrums
jahr aus einer regierungskommission aus
der letzten legislatur stammte und die
union daran mitgewirkt hat deswegen hier
nochmal ja die verbindenden worte von
katrin budde zu ende
zum ende ihrer rede so jonas geissler
ist der nächste für die cdu/csu-fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
kollegin ute wir bedanken uns gleich am
anfang für das statement am schluss weil
wir uns die einbindung natürlich
gewünscht hätten weil es ein gemeinsames
projekt ist es ist ein gemeinsames
projekt der vergangenen bundesregierung
was es jetzt gilt in die zukunft
fortzuführen und ich glaube es ist auch
ein gemeinsames projekt des ost und west
miteinander verbindet genau so wie sie
das dargestellt haben weil es ein
projekt ist wo es einfach um vertrauen
geht mein
mein wahlkreis coburg kronach
geroldsgrün liegt im norden bayerns
direkt an der ehemaligen innerdeutschen
grenze
wir sind also ich bin jetzt ein sauber
kind der wiedervereinigung in
anführungszeichen ich kann mich an die
trennung nur als kleinkinder enger aber
ich habe den einigungsprozess erlebt und
zwar genau mit dem blickwinkel der uns
in der grenzregion jeden tag aufs neue
beschäftigt hat weil wir erlebt haben
wie die menschen in ostdeutschland
arbeitslos geworden sind weil wir erlebt
haben wie demographie eine region
beeinflusst zwar wir erlebt haben dass
es auch auswirkungen auf das nördliche
bayern hatte weil wir erlebt haben dass
grenzen weggefallen sind und dass
freundschaften entstanden sind auf
beiden seiten der grenze ich war am
vergangenen sonntag beim oberfränkischen
bezirksschützentag er hat das erste mal
stattgefunden nicht im nordbayern
sondern in südthüringen und zwar in
sonnenberg unter dem stichwort schützen
überwinden grenzen war eine tolle
veranstaltung die sich in einer
tradition wieder gefunden hat die wir
auf fränkischer seite ein paar jahre
vorher angefangen haben nämlich dass wir
den tag der franken auch zum ersten mal
in thüringen veranstaltet haben vor dem
bewusstsein dass franken nicht an den
bayerischen landesgrenzen endet sondern
dass es eben auch einen fränkischen teil
thüringens gibt das ist genau das
das ist genau das was uns in der
grenzregion ausmacht dass man
zusammenarbeitet dass man zusammenlebt
und dass man auch gemeinsam themen setzt
und ich glaube im zukunftszentrum ist
auch sowas möglich
weil der titel an sich ich muss ehrlich
zugeben als ich ihn das erste mal gehört
habe habe ich gedacht er ist ein sehr
sehr sperriger titel
passt weil er beschreibt nämlich genau
das worauf es ankommt einen
unglaublichen transformationsprozess
eine zukunftsperspektive und eine
deutsche einheit die zugleich
europäische einheit ist und das muss
unser anspruch für die zukunft zeigen
gehen wir jetzt auch weiterführen
als am 11 april die unterzeichner des
briefes mehr die europäische dimension
beim zentrum für europäische
transformationen deutschen einheit in
den blickwinkel und im mittelpunkt zu
stellen
unterzeichnet haben hatten sie in vielen
punkten recht weil wir sehen gerade dass
das was wir in deutschland auf dass wir
so stolz sein können im sinne einer
demokratisierung im sinne einer einheit
die entstanden ist im sinne einer
freiheit auch rückabgewickelt werden
kann freiheit ist nicht ein weg der in
eine richtung geht freiheit kann sich
auch umkehren wenn jemand vor 15 jahren
am roten platz in moskau mit einem
schild gestanden wäre und demonstriert
hätte stünde er da den ganzen tag heute
steht er da keine fünf minuten jahren im
russischen parlament wird offen über die
wiedereinführung der todesstrafe
diskutiert
keiner von uns hätte gedacht dass ein
land seinen nachbarn über feld und
deswegen ist diese europäische dimension
so zentral und auch so wichtig und
und deswegen glaube ich dass es in dem
fall eben genau nicht darum geht dass
wir eine richtige provinz brüssel sind
wie das die afg gerade formuliert hat
sondern dass es darum geht dass wir
europa als einheit denken dass wir
europa als einheit sehen
die für die demokratie auf steht die für
die freiheit eintritt und genau das
können wir im zukunftszentrum
formulieren indem wir die
zivilgesellschaft einbinden in dem wir
menschen in beiden teilen deutschlands
miteinander verbinden in denen wir
menschen in ganz europa in den
mittelpunkt setzen indem wir demokratie
stärken weil das das zentrale allen
unseres gemeinwesens
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir gehen
den weg mit ihnen gemeinsame front auf
die zusammenarbeit und wir freuen uns
darauf dass wir die perspektive des
zukunfts zentrums ein bisschen erweitern
ich glaube das ist unser gemeinsamer
anspruch vielen dank
[Applaus]
jonas geissler war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt
hier
friedhelm boginski für die fdp fraktion
auch sagt er lässt sich hier in dieser
aussprache er kommt übrigens aus
brandenburg aus brandenburg bewirbt sich
die stadt frankfurt oder beispielsweise
als standort für das zukunftszentrum
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
werden wir nach mehr als 30 jahren über
die deutsche einheit sprechen klingt das
manchmal so als ob die wiedervereinigung
nach einem bestimmten zeitraum erreicht
viren oder erreicht sein muss aber dem
ist nicht so sondern die einheit ist das
ziel eines prozesses der in der
friedlichen revolution
millionen menschen im ostteil der
republik begonnen wurde und haben
dritter oktober 1990 ein zwischenziel
erreichte die staatliche einheit ein tag
der emotionen ein tag der freude der
überwindung der sed-diktatur mit seinem
unterdrückungsapparat aber es war auch
ein tag der vielen vielen individuellen
hoffnungen und wünsche für eine bessere
zukunft und dann prallten die menschen
mit ihren wünschen und vorbereitet auf
die wettbewerbsorientierte
marktwirtschaft als ehemaliger
bürgermeister der brandenburgischen
kreisstadt etwas weiter habe ich die
auswirkungen der einheit selbst erlebt
eine stadt die rund 15.000
arbeitsplätzen große betriebe verloren
hat eine stadt die von 53.000 einwohner
auf 38.000 schrumpfte bei gut
ausgebildete junge frauen junge menschen
insgesamt die stadt verließen eine stadt
die zeitweise und perspektivlosigkeit
abrutschte und rechtsextremistische
gewalttaten zu beklagen hatte die
menschen im östlichen teil der republik
mussten sich den schmerzhaften
entwicklungen und umbrüchen stellen
eberswalde hat auch bildung kultur und
zivilgesellschaft gesetzt und jeden
einzelnen menschen der sich weiter
entwickeln wollte und konnte
bildung kultur und zivilgesellschaft ist
das grundkonzept wenn wir heute über das
zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit und
europäischen transformation sprechen die
schaffung
dieses zentrums ist ausdruck des willens
die gesellschaftlichen endlich vor
während und nach dem system umbrechen
besser zu verstehen und
praxisorientierte lehren daraus ziehen
was können wir gemeinsam in deutschland
besser machen aber gleichzeitig auch
darauf achten wie es unseren mittel
osteuropäischen nachbarn in der
transformation ergangen ist und wie wir
mit gegenseitigen verständnis die
europäische freiheitliche demokratische
zukunft gestalten können ein schlüssel
dabei ist die anerkennung und
wertschätzung jedes einzelnen menschen
und seiner biografie aber auch das
vertrauen darauf mit bildung kultur
einer starken zivilgesellschaft und mit
den erfahrungen der vergangenheit die
zukunft erfolgreich zu gestalten und
jetzt der letzte satz mit dem
zukunftszentrum für deutschland einheit
und europäische transformation schaffen
wir hierfür die grundlage herzlichen
dank
vielen dank herr vilimsky
damit schließt sich die aussprache und
wir kommen zur abstimmung
tagesordnungspunkt 4 a hier kommen die
anzahl der fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp auf drucksache 1857 mit
dem titel ein zukunfts zentrum für
europäisch transformationen und deutsche
einheit schaffen die fraktion der spd
bündnis 90 grüne und fdp wünschen
abstimmung in der sache die fraktion cdu
csu gewünschte überweisung an den
ausschuss für kultur und medien nun bin
ich gespannt wir stimmen das ständige
übung zuerst der antrag auf ausweisung
ab ich frage deshalb wäre stimmt für die
beantragte ausschuss überweise
das sind
ja das sind die oppositionsfraktion cdu
csu fdp und die linke wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die vertreter der
regierungskoalition damit ist der
überweisungs antrag abgelehnt wir kommen
daher zur abstimmung über den antrag auf
drucksache
1857 in der sache wer stimmt für diesen
antrag
der stimmt dagegen
enthält sich dann ist dieser antrag bei
enthaltung der fraktion raf die und
linke mit den stimmen der fraktionen des
hauses angenommen
1.4 b das war der antrag der ampel
fraktionen
der im wesentlichen unterstützung für
das zukunftszentrum für europäische
transformation und deutsche einheit ihr
signalisiert und die bundesregierung
entsprechend auffordert diesen prozess
weiter in die wege zu leiten ist ja
schon viel in der debatte gesprochen
brunnen über die standortauswahl also
das wird noch ein bisschen dauern bis
2028 soll dann dieses zentrum in
ostdeutschland entstehen verschiedene
städte haben sich ja schon beworben auch
inhaltlich muss das konzept noch etwas
detaillierter ausgearbeitet werden und
wird hier auch das parlament auf die ein
oder andere weise noch weiter
beschäftigen auch der ostbeauftragte der
bundesregierung carsten schneider hat ja
angekündigt dass er auch in die städte
reisen will die sich bewerben wir kommen
zum nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
hier an diesem mittwochnachmittag
es geht dabei auch unterstützung für die
geflüchteten aus der ukraine gibt es
zwei anträge
dazu in der debatte jetzt zunächst die
staatsministerin beim bundeskanzler die
beauftragte der bundesregierung für
migration flüchtlinge und integration
aller barack obama fan ist da dran wir
sind mitten in der umsetzung und wir
liefern
unsere masterplan heißt machen machen
machen und das hätten wir auch 2015 und
danach gebraucht aber in den fag in der
vergangenen legislatur gab es ein
innenminister der eingangs anderen
masterplan hatte er gesagt hat wir
brauchen obergrenzen irrsinnige asyl
verschärfungen und migration als mutter
aller probleme das war nicht gut und
heute gibt es eine koalition die es
besser macht die primär fortschritt und
zweck arbeitet die deutschland endlich
als modernes einwanderungsland versteht
die weiß dass flüchtlinge seien kein
beruf ist wir gehen einen anderen einen
besseren weg und es ist gut wenn die
union diesen weg auch mitgehen möchte in
den ländern dazu lade ich sie herzlich
ein
heute ist ragt 84 knapp drei monate
russischer angriffskrieg wir geben allen
schutz die aus der ukraine von frauen
kindern älteren shoah überlebenden und
drittstaatsangehörigen das geht die
bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
ländern und kommunen an wir sorgen für
ein gutes an com und gute unterbringung
wir sichern die verteilung im
bundesgebiet und das registriert wird
mit amtshilfe mit pick station und dem
neuen free system beschützen frauen und
mädchen hier sind die
sicherheitsbehörden sehr wachsam hier
ist der koordinierungskreis gegen
menschenhandel präsent an bahnhöfen und
in den unterkünften
wir stellen den paragraf 24
aufenthaltsgesetz längst die weichen auf
integration mit sicherem aufenthalt mit
deutsch lernen mit zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt
ab tag eins und das hätten wir 2015 auch
gebracht braucht
und wir ermöglichen für menschen aus der
ukraine ab dem ersten juni leistungen
nach sgb 2 und sgb 7 statt
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz dass es mal
ein meilenstein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
uns geht es um teilhabe von anfang an
für kinder in kita und schule für
jugendliche in ausbildung und
hochschulen für frauen und männer am
arbeitsmarkt und klar ist auch der bund
muss finanziell unterstützen darum haben
wir die länder und kommunen entlastet
bei der coop bei den kosten bei der
unterkunft der kinderbetreuung oder
beschulung mit insgesamt zwei milliarden
euro im november schauen wir ob das
reicht dass es gemeinsam mit den ländern
vereinbart damit war auch
ministerpräsident wüst sehr
einverstanden liebe union auch beim
roundtable ukraine dandy den der
bundeskanzler und ich im april
ausgerichtet haben ebenso klar muss sein
es darf keine ungleichbehandlung geben
es kann zum beispiel nicht sein dass
internationale studierende die aus
derselben situation aus der ukraine
fliegen hier zu einem asylverfahren
gezogen sind darum ist es richtig dass
hamburg ihn ein vorläufiges
aufenthaltsrecht zur weiterführung ihres
studiums ausstellt wir brauchen genau
diese perspektiven wir sehen bei den
geflüchteten aus der ukraine ja schon
die gute integration von anfang an
funktionieren kann deshalb brauchen wir
jetzt den verabredet neuanfang der
migration und integrationspolitik keine
arbeitsverbot schluss mit ketten duldung
integrationskurse für alle und ihre
perspektiven für einen aufenthalt wir
stellen
in den mittelpunkt nicht sein status wir
wollen menschen fördern nicht
frustrieren gemeinsam auf augenhöhe das
heißt integration da steckt unser land
und unseren zusammenhalt herzlichen dank
vielen dank
aktuelle zahlen wie viele menschen
mittlerweile beispielsweise auch nach
deutschland geflüchtet sind sind immer
etwas schwierig sie wissen das ist ja
mit der registrierung nicht
vorgeschrieben beispielsweise erst 90
tage brauchen die flüchtlinge ja keine
visum die aus der ukraine kommen stand
mitte mai sind in deutschland
mittlerweile aber auch etwa 830.000
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
registriert das geht den angaben zufolge
aus einer internen übersicht des
bundesweiten verteilt systems hervor
haben wir krieg in der ukraine seit
zwölf wochen frauen kinder und
jugendliche auf der flucht und seit
zwölf wochen machen machen machen vor
allen dingen ehrenamtliche in ganz
deutschland sie engagieren sich und
haben organisieren
hilfstransporte sie begleiten
geflüchtete auf ihrem weg in einen neuen
alltag und helfen vor ort und all diesen
ehrenamtlichen an allererster stelle
möchte ich an dieser stelle ein von
ganzem herzen danke sagt
und es braucht deutlich mehr was wissen
wir zumindest ungefähr laut angaben der
bundesregierung dass 400.000 geflüchtete
vor allen dingen frauen kinder und
jugendliche in deutschland sind was wir
sicher wissen weil die kmk mit der
vorsitzenden karin prien richtig gute
arbeit gemacht hat ist die genaue anzahl
der schülerinnen und schüler die
wöchentlich aktualisiert wird was wir
aber gar nicht wissen ist wie viele
kinder und jugendliche sich überhaupt in
deutschland aufhalten und wie viele von
denen heute ein betreuer eine betreuung
in anspruch nehmen und wie viele einen
betreuungsplatz in anspruch nehmen wolle
was wir brauchen und das sagen uns die
verbände und das sagen uns die
ehrenamtlichen dass sie vieles auf den
weg weil insbesondere die kinder und
jugendlichen jugendhilfe gut aufgestellt
ist quasi krisenerprobt ist aber sie
erzählen uns eben auch wo noch
handlungsbedarf besteht zwischen bund
ländern und kommunen also zusätzliches
personal muss gewonnen werden auch
ukrainische frauen eingebunden
abschlüsse und qualifikationen
leichter anerkannt werden wir brauchen
konkrete maßnahmen finanzielle
unterstützung bei der kinderbetreuung
einen ausbau der sprach kitas darüber
hinaus ist es unsere gemeinsame aufgabe
mit den ländern ein bedarfsorientiertes
unterstützungsprogramm für die
geflüchteten kinder und jugendlichen zum
beispiel durch den ausbau der frühen
hilfen auf den weg zu bringen aber auch
integrations und sprachkurse auszubauen
auszubauen das patenschaftsprogramm
menschen stärken menschen auszuweiten zu
diesen massnahmen sagen sie mit der
ablehnung unseres plans nein wir werden
an unseren forderungen festhalten und
ziehen die bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltes morgen einbringen und
entsprechend finanziell hinterlegen ich
danke allen die daran mitgewirkt haben
und vor allen dingen allen
ehrenamtlichen vielen dank silvia war
das für die unionsfraktion ja die beiden
anträge die dieser debatte zu grunde
liegen also jener der cdu csu fraktion
auch jener der linksfraktion die stamm
von anfang april mittlerweile ist
einiges geschehen will ja breher für die
union sagt zumindest nicht genug was
sagen die grünen filiz polat jetzt
von cdu und csu war schon bei seiner
ersten lesung überholt daran hat sich
bis heute nichts geändert im gegenteil
anfang april beklagten sie hier
stillstand planlosigkeit hebräer sie
haben das wieder getan bei der
bewältigung der schrecklichsten flucht
krise in europa seit ende des zweiten
weltkrieges und das wohlgemerkt wenige
stunden nachdem bund und länder auch
ihre länder sich auf ein
vorausschauendes und ein pragmatisches
paket zur aufnahme von geflüchteten aus
der ukraine verständigt hatten nicht auf
der höhe der zeit sie also sie nicht
etwa die bundesregierung oder die
bundesländer und im übrigen auch nicht
die kommunen meine damen und herren
hier angestaubte antrag inklusive einem
dutzend forderung und mängelliste war
schon war und ist schon längst in beiden
teilen abgearbeitet das hat
staatsministerin cavalli radovan gerade
erläutert dabei verehrte kollegin aus
der union geht es nämlich auch anders
geben sie nicht nur vor sie hätten
plötzlich ein herz für geflüchtete
entdeckt sondern handeln sie auch so
nehmen sie sich gerne ein beispiel an
ihrem kieler parteifreund daniel günther
der gegenentwurf in der
flüchtlingspolitik zu ihrem
fraktionschef märz eine fortschrittliche
an den menschen ausgerichtete
flüchtlingspolitik der politik ist das
leitprinzip dieser koalition und daran
liebe kolleginnen von der unionsfraktion
sollten auch sie sich langsam
orientieren wir brauchen weniger märz
und dobrindt wir brauchen weniger
demokratinnen die mit ihrer
flüchtlingspolitik ängste gegenüber
geflüchteten schüren und einwanderinnen
als probleme definieren überholen sie
mit ihrer flüchtlingspolitik die afd
nicht rechts damit tun sie unserer
demokratie kein gefallen und sich selbst
auch nicht
lassen sie uns da dessen gemeinsam
schritte gehen die uns voran bringen
nehmen wir einfach die kernstücke des
bund länder gibt es vom siebten april
vor staatsministerin hat erwähnt
geflüchtete aus der ukraine werden in
die grundsicherung aufgenommen letzte
woche verabschiedet damit sind die
menschen in der gkv und
krankenversichert und ich möchte auch
noch mal betont einen meilenstein in der
flüchtlingspolitik in deutschland zwei
milliarden euro seitens des bundes für
länder und kommunen bei der aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine frau bremer
davon eine milliarde für unterkunft und
grundsicherung und eine milliarde für
alle weiteren aufwendungen
kinderbetreuung durch schulungen etc den
aktuellen
dramatischen herausforderungen begegnen
wir gemeinsam geschlossen entschlossen
wir machen und sie schreiben masterpläne
von gestern seien sie also nicht immer
dagegen machen sie mit machen sie mit
bei unserer integrationsoffensive machen
sie mit bei einer progressiven
menschenrechts orientierten politik das
ständige schüren von ängsten dass sie
betreiben ihre spalte rey unserer
vielfältigen einwanderungsgesellschaft
ist einer christlichen partei unwürdig
meine damen und herren wir laden sie
dazu ein bei unserer zukunftsgerichteten
und pragmatischen politik in der
flüchtlingspolitik mitzumachen wie alle
geflüchteten in den blick hat mit uns
gibt es keine zwei klassen von
geflüchteten und wir werden das
flüchtlings und aufenthaltsrecht
dahingehend auch korrigieren wir werden
die kettenduldungen abschaffen das wurde
schon gesagt damit schaffen wir chancen
für menschen die bereits teil unserer
gesellschaft geworden sind durch eine
praxis und lebensnah überarbeitung der
bleiberecht und da sind wir sehr stolz
darauf durch die einführung des chancen
aufenthaltsrechts meine damen und herren
viele geflüchtete wollen arbeiten wollen
arbeiten dürfen es aber nicht deshalb
von der runden liebe kolleginnen von der
union schaffen sie gemeinsam mit uns
endlich die arbeits verbote im
aufenthaltsrecht hat ein novum das muss
endlich abgeschafft werden waren stimmen
sie dagegen sie betonen unablässig die
bedeutung der familie wir machen uns
konkret stark für deren schutz statt
familien für jahre zu trennen und ihm
immer weiter hürden in den weg zu legen
wollen wir familien endlich wieder
zusammenbringen machen sie ernst und
setzen sie sich mit uns dafür ein
geflüchteten beim familiennachzug
endlich gleichzustellen und den
ehegattennachzug zu beschleunigen indem
wir den sprachnachweis vor der einreise
abschaffen meine damen und herren
wir gehen beim schutz von frauen und
opfern von menschenhandel weiter als die
frau bringen indem wir eigene und
unabhängige aufenthaltsrechte schaffen
werden das haben sie nie geschafft in
den 16 jahren
in dem wir eigene unabhängige
aufenthaltsrechte schaffen her frei ich
merke an ihrer reaktion dass sie da
getroffen sind es ist bereit
und uns liegt der schock von besonders
wohlhabenden gruppen am herzen
verfolgung und flucht können schwere
psychische folgen nach sich ziehen und
es ist diese koalition die dafür sorgt
dass betroffene adäquate hilfe bekommen
und die psychosoziale hilfen zum ersten
mal finanziell massiv aufgestockt werden
und da bin ich ministerin paust sehr
sehr dankbar für meine damen und herren
der überfall auf die ukraine hat
unendlich viel leid
zerstörung und traumatisierung gebracht
wir wissen nicht wie lange dieses grauen
noch andauern wird aber wir werden alles
tun um den verfolgten zu helfen ob hier
bei uns oder in der ukraine vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit wir lehnen den
antrag ab bevor er
filiz polat weiteres für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen genau im anschluss
an die debatte wird also überlegen beide
anträge der fraktionen der cdu und auch
der linken abgestimmt werden
und filiz polat hat ja gesagt die
anträge von anfang april die hätten sich
überholt mariana harder kühnel für die
afg
frauen und kindern die vor dem krieg in
der ukraine flüchten müssen geholfen
werden muss denn schließlich handelt es
sich um echte flüchtlinge die kulturen
dankbar und rückkehr wenig sind etwa 90
prozent der ukrainischen flüchtlinge
sind frauen und kinder
die kulturfreunde migranten aus dem
arabischen und afrikanischen raum sind
hingegen zu 70 männer
ukrainische männer stehen an der front
und bringen ihre frauen und kinder in
sicherheit merkels mit kranken stehen
vor dem sozialamt und bringen vor allem
sich in sicherheit in wirtschaftliche
sicherheit das ist der unterschied
richtig ist dass sie von der union eine
registrierung aller ukrainischen
flüchtlinge unmittelbar nach dem
grenzübertritt fordern das macht sinn
gar keine frage aber warum fordern sie
dass erst jetzt warum nicht schon 2015
als sie selbst regiert haben und warum
fordern sie das nur für ukrainische
flüchtlinge waren nicht für alle
flüchtlinge und migranten und wer soll
ausgerechnet ihnen glauben dass sie es
jetzt besser machen würden wohl nur
menschen mit stockholm-syndrom
aber forderungen das schutzzonen
bartlosen um ukrainische kinder und
frauen von menschenhändlern zu schützen
und vor anderen kriminell ist richtig
aber wo war wäre schutzzonen bisher bei
den vielen sexuellen übergriffen in
flüchtlingsunterkünften oder in der
kölner silvesternacht es ist sehr schön
dass es sich hier als law and order
partei inszenieren wir sollten die
menschen wissen dass es eben nur eine
inszenierung ist
schmerzlich erfahren musste dass eine 18
jährige ukrainerin aus angst vor dem
krieg flüchtete sie aus der ukraine nach
deutschland und nun nun flüchtete sie
aus angst vor erneuter vergewaltigung
von deutschland nach polen in einer
düsseldorfer flüchtlingsunterkunft wurde
sie von zwei männern aus nigeria und
tunesien vergewaltigt bei dem tunesier
hieß es zunächst der wäre aus dem irak
das offenbart das ganze migrations chaos
ein chaos für das sie von der cdu
mitverantwortlich sind
in polen fühlt sich diese junge frauen
und sicher also dem land das sie woche
für woche im eu parlament wegen
angeblich mangelnder rechtstaatlichkeit
mit sanktionen drangsalieren wollen aber
wenn es da und vor lauter angst von
deutschland nach polen flüchten wo er
stand das unrecht in polen oder nicht
etwa doch in deutschland warum erwähne
ich das ganz einfach der ukrainischen
frauen und kindern und anderen echten
flüchtlingen helfen möchte braucht eine
entsprechende infrastruktur
doch diese infrastruktur ist ausgelastet
warum ist sie ausgelastet unter anderem
weil etwa 300.000 ausreisepflichtige
ausländer nicht abgeschoben werden und
warum werden sie nicht abgeschoben weil
es hier zu jeder politische wille fehlt
der ukrainischen frauen und kindern und
anderen echten flüchtlingen helfen
möchte muss ausreisepflichtige ausländer
endlich abschieden so schafft man die
erforderlichen kapazitäten so sind
ukrainische frauen und kinder auch in
deutschland sichern also helfen wir
denen die hilfsbedürftig dankbar und
rückkehr willig sind aber nicht gehen
die nur aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
hierher gekommen sind und ihre frauen
und kinder zurückgelassen haben
angesichts des seit 2005 10
angerichteten schadens reicht der
sogenannte masterplan für ukrainische
frauen und kinder nicht aus was wir
brauchen ist eine echte kehrtwende in
der asylpolitik
umfassende kontrollen der deutschen
außengrenze lückenlose registrieren und
erfassung der identität zurückweisung
von trittbrettfahrer mit gefälschten
ukrainischen testen konsequente
abschiebung aller vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtigen dann nur dann haben
wir die kapazitäten ukrainischen frauen
und kinder zu helfen und dann auch nur
dann wenn italienische frauen und kinder
aber auch deutsche bürger in deutschland
wieder sicher seien vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin haderten
nächster redner ist der kollege stephan
thomae fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sich eine
frau präsidentin fähre kolleginnen
kollegen
der kriege die ukraine bestimmt
weiterhin die diskussion bei uns in der
öffentlichkeit den letzten wochen
natürlich vor allem das thema
waffenlieferungen etwas in den
hintergrund in der rezession ist
getreten dass im inland in ganz europa
auch viel humanitäre hilfe für
geflüchtete personen geleistet wird ja
natürlich lief nicht immer alles überall
perfekt das wird auch niemand verlangt
und erwartet haben in so einer situation
die die schnell eintritt aber ich finde
doch das verglichen mit früheren
flüchtlings krisen innerhalb weniger
wochen funktionierte abläufe bei uns im
land stattgefunden haben und deswegen
bild auch ich natürlich den vielen
ehrenamtlern an der stelle dank sein es
ist nicht einfach nur stereotypes
pflicht üben sondern ich empfinde das
wirklich so weil ja wir alle auch in den
wahlkreisen wissen was geleistet wird
vor ort von vielen freiwilligen
hilfsbereiten menschen die andere
menschen aus der ukraine aufnehmen aber
schon auch die vielen mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den städten den
gemeinden den landkreisen die ebenfalls
viele leistungen erbringen auch ihnen
muss man danken für ihren einsatz und
ich will schon auch betonen
in den letzten wochen wirklich viel
geschehen ist bei uns im land will nur
ein paar beispiele erwähnt über
113000 ukrainische kinder und
jugendliche sind mittlerweile bei
unseren schulen eingeschult worden das
ist immens wichtig weil die kinder und
jugendlichen doch den hauptleidtragenden
gehören und jetzt alles tun müssen dass
nicht auch noch schulisch weit
zurückgeworfen werden und den anschluss
verlieren deswegen ist es ungeheuer
wichtig dass auch die
bundesbildungsministerin war auch stark
watzinger immer wieder darauf hinweist
und auch die leeren lehrer die ja oft im
zentrum der kritik stehen wirklich
vieles leisten um diese kinder und
jugendliche auch mitzunehmen auch ihnen
gilt unser dank weil dann und herne
oder ein anderes thema das in dem antrag
auf eine medizinische versorgung ab dem
ersten sechs ist es möglich das
ukrainische geflüchtete bei uns
grundsicherung erhalten was ihre
versorgungsmöglichkeiten erheblich
verbessert auch da zeigt sich doch schon
was ich ungeheuer viel getan hat und
noch weiter tut oder weiterer punkt
zugang zum arbeitsmarkt ja viele
menschen der ukraine kommen hoffen jeden
tag darauf dass sie bald zurückkehren
können die werden nicht versuchen bei
dem arbeitsmarkt fuß zu fassen aber
andere tun das sehr wohl und da öffnen
wir jetzt den weg ebenfalls über den
rechtskreis wechsel dass sie in der
arbeitsvermittlung unterkommen können
bei uns im arbeitsmarkt auch das zeigt
dass ich ungeheuer viel schon getan hat
und weiterhin tut meine damen und herren
was aber natürlich nicht heißt dass noch
viel zu tun ist natürlich das ist ganz
klar ich persönlich bin der meinung dass
wir vor allem eine gesamteuropäische
bestandsaufnahme brauchen eine
verlässliche
möglichst vollständigen datenbasis ein
lagebild um zu wissen wie geht es den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bei uns aber
auch in polen in ungarn der slowakei in
rumänien aber nicht auch bei uns in
deutschland in frankreich in spanien in
portugal viele von ihnen werden lange
zeit bei uns in europa bleiben viele
haben persönliche bleibe wünsche weil
sie irgendwo in europa angehörige
freunde und bekannte haben wo sie schon
untergekommen sind aber wir sind auch
die leistungsfähigkeit und die
möglichkeiten dieser länder in betracht
ziehen ein anderer punkt den ich für
wichtig erachte in den ersten tagen und
wochen war unser regierungshandeln
krisenmanagements in angedacht der der
situation aber wir müssen jetzt
natürlich
gesamteuropäisch mehr und mehr
übergehend zu vorausschauendem
langfristigen entwickelt von
perspektiven und langzeit pläne niemand
weiß wie lange dieser krieg und das
geschehen noch andauert alles ist schwer
berechenbar die katastrophe inmitten
europas dauert weiter an aber müssen
denkbare szenarien vorbereiten und auch
dann wenn öffentliche öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit nachlässt uns gedanken
machen wie wir den menschen die hier
bleiben wollen hier bleiben werden
perspektiven und möglichkeiten zu bieten
sie werden aber auch auf lange zeit
sowohl bei uns im land ukrainisch
stämmige als auch russisch stämmige
menschen haben und müssen die
gesellschaft und die behörden darauf
vorbereiten dass da was auch
konfliktpotenzial erwachsen kann und
müssen insbesondere darauf achten dass
russisches russischsprachige menschen
sich aber über inländische medien in
russischer sprache informieren können um
nicht angewiesen seien auf informationen
aus russland und willich als fazit
festhalten dass wir herausforderungen
vielfältig und dauerhaft bleiben werden
und ständige anpassungen erfordern
insofern ist der antrag der union ob von
anfang an nicht ganz up to date gewesen
ist es nicht geworden deswegen werden
verstehen dass wir ihnen heute nicht
zustimmen können die regierung ist up to
date und handelt nach einem
funktionierenden masterplan ich danke
sagt stephan thomae für die fdp fraktion
und jetzt wird die nächste rednerin
klarer bünger wird es sein für die linke
die sprecherin für flucht politik der
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind sehr
froh über alle gesetzlichen
erleichterungen die für geflüchtete aus
der ukraine auf den weg gebracht werden
es bleibt aber die frage warum gelten
sie nicht für alle menschen die vor dem
russischen angriffskrieg ziehen müssen
es ist nicht ganz so wie frau
staatsministerin alaba lira die bahn
gerade gesagt habe es werden nicht alle
gleich behandelt die bundesregierung
schafft ein system von geflüchteten
erster und zweiter klasse für viele
tritt starterin hat das zur folge dass
sie momentan nicht wissen wie sie über
die runden kommen sollen sie wollen
einfach nur studieren oder arbeiten
warum wird ihnen das so schwer gemacht
darin abdel asis kommt aus marokko und
hat medizin in der ukraine studiert sie
hat mir berichtet dass sie nicht
versteht warum sie jetzt nicht wie
andere geflüchtete aus der ukraine
einfach weiter studieren kann und ich
verstehe das ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
es macht keinen sinn sein unser
scheidung kümmern dass sich jetzt einige
bundesländer selbst spezifische lösungen
überlegen hätte vermieden werden können
wenn sie die internationalen
studierenden einfach in den schutz nach
§ 24 einbezogen hätten so wie es frau
feser auch ursprünglich versprochen
hatte was es braucht ist eine bundes ein
etliche lösung
ein anderes thema bei dem die
bundesregierung hinter ihren
ankündigungen zurück bleibt ist der
umgang mit russischen deserteuren bzw
kriegsdienstverweigerer in der
regierungsbefragung vor zwei monaten
hatte frau feser erklärt sie sei hierzu
auf eu-ebene in gesprächen man wolle
handeln ich habe davon aber nichts mehr
gehört es fehlen auch klare signale zur
unterstützung von oppositionellen aus
russland der spiegel berichtete von etwa
70 personen darunter kultur und
medienschaffende und ihre familien die
sich mit einem in wenigen wochen
ablaufenden touristenvisum in
deutschland aufhalten offenbar streiten
das auswärtige amt und das bmi seit
wochen ergebnislos darüber wie ihn die
weitere aufenthalt ermöglicht werden
soll das kann doch nicht sein dass dem
verweis dazu auch heute morgen wieder im
innen auch die möglichkeit eines
asylantrags das hätte für die
betroffenen zur folge dass sie in ein
aufnahmelager verteilt und einem
arbeitsverbot unterliegen würden zukunft
ungewiss das ist doch kein schutz
angebot das ist eine bürokratische
verhinderung einer klaren lösung wir
machen den vorschlag dass sie auf der
innenministerkonferenz im juni eine
aufenthaltsregelung der paragraf 23
absatz 1 aufenthaltsgesetz schaffen um
diese gruppe ein schutz in deutschland
zu bieten weiterhin problematisch ist
auch die lage für aktivistinnen die
bislang nicht aus russland ausreisen
konnten oder sich in drittstaaten
aufhalten und dringend einen sicheren
frucht fluchtweg in die eu benötigen
auch hierzu bz wochen über mögliche
aufnahme regelungen gerungen aber nichts
passiert ich fordere sie auf lassen sie
den ankündigungen endlich taten folgen
handeln sie endlich hier vielen dank
fordert hierfür die linksfraktion deren
abgeordnete clara bünger und sieht eben
die forderung aus dem antrag der linken
von anfang april der hier beraten wird
und dann auch im anschluss abgestimmt
diese forderungen sind sie längst mich
erfüllt hell gelingt jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten er ist der sprecher für
demokratie
frau präsidentin die liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
verkünden sie haben gerade eine neue
kategorie der textform etabliert den
rassistischen slapstick die nicht dafür
dankbar habe das aber zur kenntnis
genommen ich will dass nur noch mal
wiederholen machen es glaube ich
deutlich machen auch vor allem die hier
im raum
zeugen sind und ein bildschirm und sonst
wo sie sprachen ja davon echten
flüchtlingen kultur nahe und dankbar ich
zitiere und dann von kultur fremd
migranten nackte rassistisch geht es
nicht ein
los geht es allerdings gerade sitzen
hier im bundestag diverse schulklassen
auf den tribünen und ich bin mir absolut
sicher dass ein großteil der dort
anwesenden mit schaudern sich innerlich
weg gewandt hat von ihrem vortrag und
diejenigen werden in den nächsten
jahrzehnten mit ihrem wahlverhalten
dafür sorgen dass die auf dem august der
vergessenheit landen wird
also die realität wird sie widerlegt so
viel vorab geschickt von ihrem
unterirdischen beitrag kommen wir jetzt
zum antrag der cdu fraktion
ich wünschte mir aber das ist sozusagen
cdu/csu ich habe vergessen muss sich
richtigerweise sagen dass sie diesen
impetus und diesen drang
vulnerabilität von geflüchteten
anzuerkennen auch auf andere gruppen
ausweiteten oder wünscht sich mehr auch
ein bisschen historische redlichkeit
denn in der vergangenheit habe ich
diesen impetus und diesen drang bei ihm
nicht wirklich verspürt da müssen wir
selbst auch und wir hatten eine
koalition miteinander und müssen auch
mal selbstkritisch gucken was es uns
gelungen was nicht gelungen und ein
vorstoß massiver vorstoß zur schützt zum
schutz seiner person zb
aufnahmeeinrichtung und ähnlichen ist an
ihrem widerstand gescheitert auf diese
tatsache muss man hinweisen jetzt das in
bezug auf die im kreml zu fordern ist
nicht schlecht aber nicht hinreichend
ist auch deswegen nicht hinreichend weil
sie sich damit dem verdacht aussetzen
der double standards und wenn man es
ganz zuspitzt auch der bigotterie und
scheinheiligkeit denn wenn wir etwas
brauchen dann brauchen wir solche
schutzkonzepte für alle geflüchteten
personen und wenn man sich etwas in
dieser republik bewegt zeigt die
situation das ist bedauerlich es ist
aber so dass viele geflüchtete aus
unterschiedlichen ländern die vor der
ukraine krise gekommen sind verbittert
sind und sagen warum haben wir nicht die
möglichkeiten erhalten und dieses feuer
der unzufriedenheit glüht sie schütten
aber noch öl in dieses feuer und das
achte ich also unredlich und nicht in
ordnung die antwort
die antwort kann dann aber im übrigen
nicht sein nicht alles mögliche und
verbesserung des systems für ukrainerin
oder trainer auf dem weg zu bringen aber
sich anzugucken wie die gesamtsituation
ist wenn sie dann fordern lassen wir uns
um psychosoziale belastung von
jugendlichen kümmern müssen früher
hilfen dann bitte ich sie dass zu
ergänzen dass sie endlich mit ihnen mit
ihrer laut unterstützung von der ich
jetzt ausgehe etwas für psychosoziale
zentren und andere institutionen machen
können die haben nicht gerade die
rückendeckung der cdu und csu weder
bundesrepublikanischen noch in cdu
geführten ländern im letzten jahren
erfahren und dann möchte ich noch etwas
sagen weil sie ja gerade zufällig artig
die registrierung hier voranbringen
neben der rechtslage ist gerade nicht
zulässt also müsste man sagen sie wollen
eine neue rechtliche grundlage
sagen sie aber auch nicht dass das
heißen würde wenn das an der grenze
grenznah erfolgen soll das wir
flächendeckend grenzkontrolle haben
sonst kann man nicht grenznahe jeden
kontrollieren wenn nicht kontrolliert
wird und dann möchte ich noch erinnern
an den achter april eine rede von herrn
hoffmann im protokoll nachzulesen
und er zitierte da ein fall aus dem
medien- und sagte dann dass es die
situation gebe dass am berliner
hauptbahnhof die bundespolizei
kontrollieren und dann ich zitiere sich
in einem zug augen steht augenscheinlich
augenscheinlich personen befinden die
nicht aus der ukraine kommen ich habe
bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
verstanden wie man augenscheinlich
feststellen kann ob es ihm aus der matte
zuschauer wir verabschieden uns
kurzfristig sirene schon der vorschau es
gibt ein gipfeltreffen auf einladung der
dänischen regierung der regierungschefs
zu einem chefin von dänemark belgien
niederlanden und deutschland in der
dänischen hafenstadt esbjerg und es wird
unterzeichnet der ausbau der gemeinsamen
ausbau der windenergie ist soll eine
pressekonferenz geben unter anderem mit
bundeskanzler schulz
die energiewende stehen wir vor großen
herausforderungen
weitere herausforderungen die die
volkswirtschaften in der eu und die
bürgerinnen und bürger
gehen wir einen wichtigen
um diese herausforderungen anzugehen wir
alle haben eine gemeinsame vision wir
möchten die nordsee zu einem grünen
kraftwerk machen wir möchten ein
integriertes grünes energiesystem
schaffen wir möchten den übergang zu
einer grünen energie ermöglichen wir
möchten die abhängigkeit von putins gas
reduzieren tausende neue arbeitsplätze
schaffen und
ebenso möchten wir eine grünere
sicherere zukunft für uns alle schaffen
wir
verpflichten uns
sehr viele offshore windräder zu bauen
nämlich in unsere kapazitäten
vervierfachen bis 2030 und bis 2050
14-fachen
konkret bedeutet die ist dass die vier
von uns über die hälfte des offshore
wind zur verfügung stellen der für die
klimaneutralität in der eu nötig ist es
freut mich selbstverständlich heute hier
den hafen es ja meinen kollegen zeigen
zu können mit sieben gestalten das war
einfach werden da stellt sich nur die
frage wie kann das passieren
wie kann das sein dass irgendwie nicht
registrierten helfer so genannten helfer
überhaupt diese hilflosigkeit von diesen
geflüchteten frauen ausnutzen können da
brauchen wir lösungen dazu da brauchen
wir flächendeckende registrierung auch
wenn der kollege gesagt hat wir würden
da gebetsmühlenartig darauf bereiten
aber scheinbar ist es nötig dass so was
nicht passieren können wir brauchen auch
einen starken staat dafür dass diese
ukrainischen flüchtlinge hier
entsprechend untergebracht und so werden
können
auf der anderen seite haben wir diese
ehrenamtler da habe einen kennen dann
der seit 20 jahren in deutschland lebt
er kommt aus kasachstan arbeitet
vollzeit als bauingenieur und ist drei
mal die woche ist seit mitte märz hier
und opfert seinen urlaub und seine
stunden und bringt es gerne einmal
einfach helfen will aber wenn wir diese
hilfe nicht hätten diese belastungen die
die ehrenamtler aushalten und tragen da
brauchen wir heute staatliches konzept
da brauchen wir doch entsprechende
unterstützung da braucht man auch ein
plan dazu dazu gehört auch dass die
kinder die hier kommen die in einer
fremden welt ihr einkommen die in die
schulen kommen die die sprache nicht
können in kitas und so weiter
entsprechend auch gefördert werden
können auch dafür doch irgendwo das
konzept für die schnelle integration
dass sie hier eine neue heimat mit
finden und da habe ich einfach meine
zweifel dass diese lage vollumfänglich
von der regierung umrissen worden ist
und die entsprechenden ressourcen dazu
geschaffen werden egal da braucht man
kein genie sein dass uns hier die
entsprechenden leute führen dass uns
hier entspannen ressourcen und
persönlichkeiten mit vielen deswegen
haben wir eine reihe von
herausforderungen zu bestehen will ich
gar nicht kleinreden das gilt egal ob
man der regierung der opposition ist und
das ist die aufgabe unseres staates
dafür zu sorgen dass es die ukrainischen
flüchtlingen in unserem land gut geht
und diese an der hand zu nehmen deswegen
vielen dank für die unterstützung
unseres antrags
die kollegin gülistan liebsten spricht
jetzt uns für die erste gefahr
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen so sehr ich
mich über die gelegenheit voll über das
wichtige thema der integration zu
sprechen zu sprechen so sehr wenig
verwundert dass die union anscheinend
ihr herz für die zu uns kommen den
menschen entdeckt hat lassen sie mich
kurz drei ziele zitate vorlesen asyl
urlaube auf heimat trip können gleich
bleiben wo sie hergekommen sind
die migrationsfrage ist die mutter aller
politischen probleme in diesem land
wir brauchen ein einwanderungs
begrenzungs gesetz mit vorrang für
zuwanderer auf unserem christlich amt
ländlichen kulturkreis was wir hier
gerade gehört haben sind nicht etwa
aussagen dfg auch wenn sie klatschen
nein es sind aussagen der letzten jahre
aus den reihen der union
auch in meiner mehr als 30-jährigen
integrationsarbeit habe ich viele
blockaden und ressentiments der union
miterlebt sah es beim kommunalen
wahlrecht sei es bei der doppelten
staatsbürgerschaft unter unsäglichen
unterschriftenkampagne hierzu bei den
debatten zum zuwanderungsgesetz
oder die immer wiederkehrenden
diskussionen über eine leitkultur
der rote faden der sich bei der union zu
migrationsthemen durchzieht ist das
narrativ von wir gegen die anderen
immer wieder wurde die
integrationsarbeit ob auf kommunaler
landes- oder bundesebene durch die union
blockiert und erschwert
denn
wenn die union das jetzt anders sieht
ist das ganz gut ich hoffe nur dass
diese besserung auch nachhaltig ist und
sich ihre solidarität auf alle
geflüchteten und der hier lebenden
menschen erstreckt
liebe zu leben und zu lieben ist es
wichtig und richtig dass wir die zu uns
flüchtenden menschen aus der ukraine
schnell und unbürokratisch aufnehmen und
ihnen zugang zu sprachkursen und dem
arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen es darf aber
nicht darum gehen für welchen krieg die
menschen zu uns fliehen für alle gilt
der grundsatz arbeit sprache bildung und
begegnung von anfang an wir brauchen
daher zum beispiel auch die abschaffung
von arbeits verboten und kettenduldungen
da sind ja einige kollegen schon darauf
eingegangen
ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen es
darf keine menschen erster und zweiter
klasse geben
der werte dahinter
integration ist ein prozess ein prozess
bei dem alle beteiligten seiten
aufeinander zugehen müssen wenn wir
durch unsere politik die gemeinschaften
die wertschätzung eltern fördern und
fordern und stärken dann kann
integration nach nachhaltig gelingen
dann ist integration eine bereicherung
für unser land und da ja die union
anscheinend ihr herz für die integration
entdeckt hat freue ich mich schon zu
sehen wie sie zukünftig auf unsere
vorhaben reagieren wie sehr sind sie
alle mit ihren handys beschäftigt ich
hoffe dass sie zugehört haben vielen
dank
für die cdu csu fraktion spricht der
kollege lars rohwer
glückauf präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir
haben die debatte miteinander bestritten
und wir haben alle festgestellt dass
immer mehr menschen angesichts des
barbarischen krieges des russischen
diktators putin auf der flucht sind
und ich wünsche dir noch einmal
feststellen auch für die
cdu/csu-fraktion wir müssen diesen
menschen gute gastgeber sein es sollte
unser ziel sein das ist sich in
deutschland wohlfühlen wer sich gut als
gast empfangen führt spricht auch gut
über dieses gastland welches eine neue
heimat werden kann ich sage das nicht
nur als mitglied der cdu csu fraktion
sondern auch als jemand der 2015 aus
rotkreuz vorsitzender in dresden
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung betrieben hat
und der das jetzt auch wieder bereit war
zu tun deswegen bin ich etwas irritiert
über den tonfall den ich hier vorfinde
als neues abgeordnet neues mitglied des
deutschen bundestages
weil das waren einfach nur stieg mata
und schauen sie bitte direkt hin was vor
ort stattfindet
nach meiner festen auffassung ist es so
dass wir uns im moment auf der
hilfsbereitschaft und dem engagement der
freiwilligen ausruhen ich vermisse noch
immer einen krisenstab
der bundesregierung die einen
langfristigen plan für den schutz und
die integration der schutzsuchenden
koordiniert wir schlagen mit unserem
masterplan maßnahmen vor es ist ihre
aufgabe
diese jetzt umzusetzen weil sie jetzt in
der verantwortung sind den menschen
schutz zu gewähren und integration zu
ermöglichen
durch die stabilität die kinder und
jugendliche durch den besuch einer
schule erfahren können können sie die
angst die sorgen und das erlebte besser
verarbeiten und für einige stunden auf
vergessen ein strukturierter tagesablauf
der ihnen die möglichkeit gibt
freundschaften zu knüpfen und über das
erlebte auch zu sprechen das gibt halt
hilft ihnen bei der verarbeitung des
flucht traumas und deswegen geben wir
den vertriebenen kindern und
jugendlichen aus der ukraine eine starke
bildungsperspektiven und stabilität in
deutschland
was heißt das für mich ganz konkret
wenn das größte wenn die israel mit
einer wesentlich größeren einwanderungs
quote es geschafft hat dass jede und
jeder innerhalb von drei monaten
hebräisch sprechen kann und schreiben
kann dann sollte das doch auch das ziel
der bundesregierung jetzt in deutschland
für die sprache in unserem land seien
für deutsch wir brauchen diese
strukturen wir brauchen diese
bildungskurse ganz dringend an jeder
ecke in diesem land um die menschen zu
integrieren
und was die menschen vor ort nicht
brauchen das ist eine bundespolitik die
ständig in oberlehrer man ihr sagt was
sie alles dicht richtig und was sie noch
besser machen sollen die lehrerinnen und
lehrer vor ort gehen an ihre
leistungsgrenzen nach corona kommt jetzt
der krieg und das stützen wir doch
lieber unsere lehrerinnen und lehrer
sowie die menschen die sich bei der
integration und bildungsarbeit
engagieren sagen wir ihn nicht ständig
was sie noch alles besser machen sollen
und müssen fragen dass sie eher was für
eine unterstützung benötigt wird um die
situation erfolgreich gestalten zu
können ob jedes einzelne kind zu
integrieren und zu fördern ich sehe die
schulleiterin die eine ukrainische
vertriebene frau einstellt um ein neues
bildungsangebot in ihrer schule
anzubieten ich sehe die
grundschullehrerinnen die nicht erst mal
fragt wo ist in der kurs dass ich dann
die integration machen kann die einfach
los macht die mit der sprache auf ihrem
telefon
die ukrainischen kinder versucht zu
integrieren das alles brauchen wir und
deswegen fordert sie auf die länder zu
unterstützen und den ewigen dreisatz von
geld mehr personen gute lernatmosphäre
zu fördern vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
ich schließe die aussprache und wir
kommen nun zur abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
inneres und heimat zu dem antrag der
fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem titel
masterplan hilfe sicherheit und
integration für ukrainische frauen
kinder und jugendlicher der ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 15 37 den antrag der
fraktion der cdu/csu auf drucksache 13
35 abzulegen wer stimmt für diese
beschluss im
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen linke
mehr stimmen dagegen
das ist die cdu csu fraktion werden
möchte sich enthalten dass es die
fdp-fraktion damit ist die
beschlussempfehlung angenommen und ich
komme zur abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
inneres und heimat zu dem antrag der
fraktion die linke mit dem titel
geflüchtete aus der ukraine und anderen
ländern schützen kommunen bei der
aufnahme stärken der ausschuss empfiehlt
in seiner beschlussempfehlung auf druck
seiner 15 38 den antrag der fraktion die
linke auf drucksache 13.30 abzulehnen
wer ständig für diese
beschlussempfehlung
wer stimmt dagegen
wer möchte sich enthalten vielen dank
die beschlussempfehlungen ist angenommen
dagegen hat die fraktion die linke
gestimmt es hat sich niemand enthalten
alle übrigen fraktionen haben zugestimmt
ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 6a
und 6b die beratung des antrags der
fraktionen der spd von bündnis 90 die
grünen und der fdp mit dem titel
unterstützung in bildung und forschung
für geflüchtete aus der ukraine sowie
die beratung des antrags der fraktion
der afg mit dem titel zügig pragmatische
lösungen schaffen beschulung
ukrainischer flüchtlingskinder
bestmöglich sicherstellen es ist
verabredet hierzu
39 minuten zu debattieren dazu sehe ich
keinen widerspruch
dann werden wir so verfahren und als
erstes gebe ich das wort der kollegin
rehasport schröder für die es ist falsch
die fdp-fraktion sich schaute gerade so
einsetzt erstaunt aber da alle schon
sitzen und ist beherrscht und ich sofort
da ziehen wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wunderbar das geht ja alles sehr schnell
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe durch den krieg schon so viel
verloren ich will nicht auch noch meine
zukunft verlieren diese worte einer
studentin aus der ukraine stehen für das
gefühl einer ganzen generation junger
menschen die in den letzten wochen tagen
oder gerade erst heute vor dem
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg russlands
geflohen sind dieser furchtbare krieg
ist ein feldzug gegen eine stolze
ukraine die sich selbstbewusst für
freiheitlich demokratische werte
entschieden hat zu diesen werten gehören
auch wissenschaftsfreiheit und das recht
auf bildung als grundstein einer freien
gesellschaft auch unserer gesellschaft
unsere antwort muss deshalb die stärkung
der menschen im bildungs und
wissenschaftssystem sein wir bieten
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer an unseren
bildungseinrichtungen einen sicheren
hafen
mit diesem antrag zeigen wir als
fortschritts koalition welchen beitrag
ministerin stark watzinger die länder
kommunen universitäten schulen bereits
leisten mehr als
110.000 schülerinnen und schüler
besuchen unsere schulen zu öffnen das
bafög für studierende aus der ukraine
und heißen sie in unseren hörsälen
willkommen forschenden öffnen wir die
türen zu unseren laboren und
wissenschaftszentren daran sind viele
menschen im ganzen land haupt und
ehrenamtlich beteiligt ihnen allen dafür
herzlichen dank
ein schwerpunkt liegt in unserem antrag
auf der schnellen und unbürokratischen
anerkennung bereits erworbener
qualifikationen
denn wir sehen nicht nur die
hilfsbedürftigkeit der menschen wir
sehen auch ihr potenzial die ministerin
hat dies bereits angekündigt es ist
wichtig dass das die anerkennungspraxis
so bald wie möglich flächen deckend
angepasst wird und wir setzen auf
science diplomacy wir zeigen flagge für
deutsch und klinische
forschungskooperationen und für die
unterstützung der wissenschaft
strukturen in der ukraine
putin wird sie nicht zerstören und für
den wiederaufbau von bibliotheken
universitäten und forschungslaboren
stehen wir bereit
denn das meine damen und herren bleibt
bei all unseren anstrengungen das ziel
dass die menschen so schnell wie möglich
in ihre heimat zurückkehren können ihre
zukunft ist nicht verloren geben wir
ihnen etwas mit auf den weg woran sie
anknüpfen können und was wäre wertvoller
als bildung mit unserem antrag zeigen
wir putin den mittelfinger in dem der
grausamkeit und krieg mit hoffnung und
zukunftsperspektive beantworten das
meine damen und herren das ist die kraft
der freien gesellschaft vielen dank
jedenfalls habe ich keine parlaments
unwürdigen zeichen gesehen ich hoffe ich
habe nichts übersehen und gebe das wort
der kollegin daniela ludwig für die cdu
csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich möchte zunächst mal sorgen ich finde
es ausgesprochen notwendig dass wir in
zwei aufeinander folgenden debatten über
die frage sprechen wie gehen wir gut und
erfolgreich mit den vielen menschen um
insbesondere
babys kinder jugendliche und frauen die
zu uns kommen
diese frage stellen wir uns aber
natürlich jetzt schon seit etwas
längerem
und dort kann es jetzt einfach ehrlicher
weise so sehr wir da gerne an einem
strang ziehen wollen nicht so ganz aus
der verantwortung nehmen denn was ich
bisher nur höhere ist ankündigen nicht
mehr und was ich in diesem antrag vor
allem lese ist ein dankeschön an alle
anderen die das bisher ganz besonders
toll hinbekommen haben und zwar co2 dann
kind bekommen haben ohne nennenswerte
hilfe dieser bundesregierung und das ist
in wahrheit ein absolutes armutszeugnis
für sie nach all den sonntagsreden die
sie unterhalten mit ihrem angeblich so
tollen umgang mit geflüchteten sage ich
ihnen mal eines als kreisvorsitzender
des roten kreuzes in rosenheim wenn
meine ehrenamtlichen nicht einfach
bereit gewesen wären die ersten wochen
ihre gesamte freizeit zu opfern die
feuerwehr nicht in der lage gewesen
wären aus der erfahrung aus 20 15 16 17
anzuwenden und turnhallen umzurüsten
binnen kürzester zeit dann wären diese
armen menschen mit dieser regierung
komplett aufgeschmissen gewesen und
dessen ist man einfach mal zur kenntnis
nehmen darum sage ich in den
ehrlicherweise kurzer dann kommen sie
den antrag geschrieben dieses dankeschön
des meeres angebracht denn von ihnen kam
ehrlicherweise nicht
besonders viel
deswegen ist der antrag richtig aber es
müssen natürlich trocken folgen von den
ankündigungen kann sich keiner etwas
runter beißen und schon gar nicht die
vielen menschen vor ort die immer noch
sich nicht haben entmutigen lassen und
trotzdem weitermachen und wenn wir die
verteilung sprechen ja in bayern leben
mittlerweile 35 prozent der bis heute
angekommenen flüchtlingen
natürlich mehr in den ballungsräumen das
ist auch klar
und jeden tag kommen in bayern 500